Oh, hold on. What did he say? Someone told me there's still cope
in here that I was going to there going to be criminal charges
against me. I said I felt justice wouldn't be served if you didn't
get criminal charges, but I don't know anything about that. So,
we'll see. I'm not even going to lose the civil case. I mean,
it sounded like you said you lost $850,000.
Maybe that's just not a problem. If it's if it's not that big
a deal, I suggest you stop acting like such a whiny about it.
If it is a big deal, then don't say you didn't lose. That's crazy.
Auggie be summoning this guy. What are you What are you doing,
Auggie? How did you summon this guy?
Okay. All right. All right. All right. All right. All right.
Give me a second. I think this is probably the part where we
want to talk about this.
Honor was talking to him about moral systems. Was this like a
week ago?
So eye for an eye, uh, I think you might have said this, by the
way, is that eye for an eye is technically a step in a more just
direction because if somebody pokes out your eye, I think it's
argued that Conor Connor
>> where we believe that every human being is entitled
to a certain amount of culture, I think, and I think that there's
turning the energy and turning. So turn is operating with a person
in the ultimate thing where let's say you face well I go well
no brother Christ you could be hurting Christ but you have hurt
me but I'm not going to hurt you back because ultimately I want
to see with you in future and so I'm not going to hurt you any
question um no
argue is that you can't turn the opposite so with Indian theory
what you do is impose not the same consequence it's not I it's
not that I know you can you
um basically like I get that person
or I get them fired I get them this and so there is a negative
consequence to your bad behavior but then 5 to 10% of the time
I engage in turning the other cheek hoping that we can build
a reciprocal and positive relationship >> sure this is
like um I'm sure you guys this like for like 5% forget help,
>> right? So, okay. So, we've landed here descriptively.
I think articulated the ideas where anybody with body IQ could
understand them. The reason why I think uh Israel is catching
is because they're not engaging eye for an eye turning the other
cheek. >> Okay. I So, we made it through. Okay. We made
it through. I know. I know. >> Based off of this model,
they're engaged in barbarian retributed violence. And then also,
I would say,
>> no, no, no. This is super easy to understand. Almost
everybody understands this intuitively. Literally just using
the concepts. the concepts through their explan like through
their names are already explained to me like I don't know how
to say this >> the reason why a lot of your critics even
if I don't necessarily agree with them wholeheartedly the reason
why they're critics of you and DG and doxing is because you're
not engaged in turning the other you're not engaged in tit according
to them you're engaged in barbarian retributive violence >> I
mean that's it that's the whole argument [laughter] >> okay
yeah I mean like I can see where people are coming
>> so I swear to God I have a hard time not laughing because
Connor just went through that whole thing that whole like 5 to
seven minute spiel to be like you're kind of just being like
a psycho. You're kind of just like trying to hurt people
for very little reason.
It's like [laughter] you probably could just say that coming
from I think the um the main u the main issue there's like this
third layer that exists now that we have to talk about a lot
um today because the ability for us to have um an incorrect view
of the world in some ways is like stronger than it ever has been
because you can you can make it up and put it online or whatever
and you have the ability to do that in ways that maybe people
in the past didn't quite have the ability to do that. Um, so
one of the biggest issues that I'll have when it comes to communicating
like what's been done to me is that it's just it's a lot of stuff
to keep up with. Um, and then typically just because of the way
that the communities kind of like function, usually the only
type of response I can do. So
I like at the risk of talking about stuff and directing people,
I do feel like because of other people's silence on this topic,
other people not wanting to be involved, I do get some leeway
to speak through some of these things. Okay?
And so the thing is is like I think what Destiny tries to present
as my crimes. My my main problem is is his friends were getting
doxed and harassed. Like he says, "Oh, the past year has been
crazy." No, it's been like the past two years, maybe past two
and a half years. As he's been fighting with this one specific
guy in Kiwi Farms, that guy will like go and harass. Well, I
don't know about harass. The guy will dox Destiny's friends,
loved ones, whatever, right? which is really obviously we have
a ton of condemnation for for doxing, but it's been going on
for like two and a half years. It's been going on since like
before I got really seriously into the Destiny community and
then
like after I became a streamer in the Destiny community and then
after I left the Destiny community because he
was outed as just a totally like
amoral degenerate, you know, I that happened
and so it just it was persisting through the whole thing.
Uh, I was invited by not soite on to anything else and I literally
told her I'm not face revealing like with with the way Kiwi Farms
is on like a doxing rampage right now. I'm not doing that. That's
[__] crazy,
right? And she was like, "Oh yeah, I've been, you know, swatted
multiple times," which she's talked about publicly.
Okay, so this idea that I should be the person held responsible
for that conduct is crazy to me.
And that's essentially what they've done and kind how they tried
to rewrite history is these things happened before I even
started
disliking Destiny and like doing negative content on Destiny.
Okay.
All of this was going on and he presents it. He's like, "Oh,
all my friends get doxed and harassed." It's like that sucks,
but I'm clearly not to blame for it because when I was on your
side, I was the person complaining about it. I was the person
who was like concerned about it. right now. None of that is a
reason not to criticize Destiny. None of that is a reason to
ignore Destiny or like not pay any. Yeah. Nothing like that.
Right. >> None of that is a reason to not dislike Destiny,
which by the way is the main connecting point between like Kiwi
Farms, my community, Queen's community, right? In terms of how
Destiny dislikes us, it's just that these people don't like Destiny.
It's not like a joint collective embrace of doxing as a tactic.
It's not a joint collective embrace of like real life harassment
as a tactic. It is we just don't like this guy for various reasons.
Okay.
And
so when Destiny talks about it, one of the big examples he's
brought up is Hutch. Again, Hutch was doxed by Destiny's Kiwi
Farms thread in September of 2024.
I was a part of this community, a part of his community in September
of
Right. and he's tried to lay the blame for that on Queman.
It's Erday doxed in 2024. Dan doxed in 2024
before I was when I was still in this community when I still
like a big part of that community. Okay. And so when he says
we have to talk about this extra layer, we have to talk about
all these things. He is going to try to make excuses or explain
away why he blames me for the doxing that happened in 2024.
Okay, there is I now I I'll be honest. I got somebody to go through
it.
Best I can tell,
there is no doxing that happens between the the Pixie lawsuit
where I
find out about him recording people without their consent
and I no longer a friend of his. I am pretty explicitly just
immediately I'm like you you suck. Right. Probably a little more
little more than that. probably said some extra stuff on top
of that, but I I left. Okay. Now, from that point until I believe
about June or July,
there there is no doxing. The only thing I could find was somebody
says, "Oh, someone should dox like Tom Fullery.
I can't control that. I don't want that." I when I heard about
it, I said, "Don't dox Tom. That's insane. Don't do that." Gross.
Don't do that. That's [__] like I disavow it in the
strongest possible terms. When was Zoe Jacob? Well, here's the
thing is I don't I don't want to talk too much about this stuff.
With the Hutch thing, I'm okay with the Hutch thing as like a
main point because one, Hutch has already indicated that he moved
from that address. And two, it's the same address that was a
part of the PV leaks because those happened in September of 2024,
right? Yo, is the Destiny viewbotting stuff real? I have no idea,
Auggie.
No idea, man.
I don't know. So again, I'm just I'm man, I don't know how he
blames this for this stuff. Okay,
it's crazy.
Give me a second.
I have all this stuff written down somewhere. Um, I've heard
people say this. I don't actually believe it. Uh, from what I
can tell, the community, most of like the main stays of that
community are still there. Anybody who's like a mainstay of that
community in 2024
is like still there. the kick is botted. Um
so the reason the kick chat is not the reason the kick chat rate
is not commensurate with somebody who gets that many views is
because people chat in like the DGG chat, right? Or that's the
DG chat right there.
That's why the chat is slow and kick versus the number of viewers.
But I don't know. I've never tracked how many people embed through
his site to watch on kick.
There could be like a ton of people. There could be like a thousand
people who embed via the site and watch on kick, right? I don't
know. A lot of the Reddit posters all left. Yeah, probably. His
embed count shows like 600 when he's at 2K viewers on kick. That's
a crazy difference. Well, I mean, it depends on what the multi
what the multiplier on his viewership is. If Kick's still doing
like a pretty significant multiplier on viewership, which I haven't
experienced, but I don't know how they do it between different
streams. I he has 3k viewers and 30 chatters. So again, what
I what's happening there Auggie for sure is a lot of people would
be embedding via his website right
now. It depends on how kick handles that and what's going on
there.
I do think it's kind of a really deal for Kick where like people
are embedding on their site or on through his website. They're
not chatters. They're not engaging with kick itself
and they're paying out as if
Yeah, they're paying out as if he's not doing stuff. I wonder
if he multistreams still. Whoops. Never used to watch on kick
and never embed. Well,
the only thing is I don't know why you'd embed the kick chat
or the kick video instead of YouTube,
right? You you can embed YouTube via the site. So, I don't know
why you would embed the kick stuff. Again, I hold off on the
botting thing
cuz I can just still see like a lot of genuine engagement in
a lot of different places. Like when I call Mr. Mutin the fs
slur and I get like a thousand replies from DC shears. [laughter]
So I'm I'm hesitant to call him out for botting but I also maybe
don't know
yeah fat too as well. So I'm hesitant to call it botting without
doing more investigation cuz it's it's sort of like the Fentes
thing. I don't like when people say Fentes bots because it's
like I can see all of the engagement happening in real time and
like I have a good sense for that kind of thing usually. So when
people say Fuentes bots I'm like that's cope. I do think to a
large extent with DGG that's probably also how it looks. There's
a link for chat if they want to take a look. Well let's take
a look at this. I I haven't seen whatever this is Auggie so I
can take a look. I do want to take a look.
Let's see what's going on. Destiny casually bought it to hell
and back as usual. viewers 20 2800 active chatters 33 active
emote chatters two total unique chatters 210 seven messages per
minute so I will say like
that's probably around what I get in
with like almost a tenth of the viewership so
yeah I wouldn't say it's like proof of anything right hold on
me look at my right now let's see what we're rocking right now
let's let's take a look we're currently rocking. So assuming
this is the same that they'd be using roughly the same metrics,
that's around what we'd be doing.
We had 247 on the stream yesterday
and then we go up to like 30-ish chatters, 30 to 40 chatters.
I've normally found about like 10x your chat is about what you
get for viewership,
but he's doing like almost
So that maybe that could be suspicious. Again, a lot of that
is explained by the
Like straight up, a lot of that is explained by the embeds. Does
it count the embed? Kick does count the embeds.
um I can just explain cuz I had DG embeds for a while. Um
I talked to Kick and I said, "Hey, just so you know, I I let
them know cuz I didn't want to get my KCIP docked. I was like, "Just
so you know, people embed me through this site, and I don't know
if you have like a problem with that or whatever, but I'm just
letting you know, if if Kick gets this for most people, they
will dock their their viewership. They'll like basically put
them in like a suspected botter pool where their viewership will
get cut significantly. They won't be getting paid out.
And so I let them know like, "Hey, don't don't dock my money.
Just if you could somehow filter out people embedding through
the site or something, that would help." And they're like, "No,
no, no. that's fine, that's okay. And then they set my account
in a way where it no longer applied that penalty. But I was like,
there is real engagement there. You can go and watch the chat.
Like the chat on that site like watches the stream and talks
about it.
But I I had a whole conversation with support about it. So I
don't know. It seemed like maybe for him they already had that
agreement set up and then they did something for my account.
I don't know.
Basically they started ignoring that for my account. Kick rules.
They are quite nice. I do love kick. Love kick. Love my kickas.
If Destiny loses substantial monetization on kick, I think he's
really screwed financially.
yeah, I don't know that he'd be earning like a crazy amount right
now on kick. Yeah, this happened when when like big stuff would
pop off, that's when it would happen cuz usually the whole DG
chat wouldn't embed my stream. But then if like Destiny came
on, it would go to like 1500 to 2,000 viewers sometimes and then
it would just totally cut the viewership down to like 300, 400.
You probably they don't do these anymore. Nobody has these hourly
deals anymore.
They just straight up don't do them. Isn't Destiny genuinely
rich by now though? Uh, he should be. Another tweet from that
account.
This is Whiz. This guy does a lot of stuff talking about like
um viewership and
on Twitch. Four botters, one couch. Oh man, you going to throw
sketch in there with them? That's okay.
All right. This up. Does he still pop in here? I haven't seen
him in a long time, but I I have him like uh filtered so I don't
even see him chat.
I I assume he hasn't because I haven't seen other people talk
about it. I think we just saw So, one of the clips we'll watch
eventually here is I think we go
uh I think he says he spent like 850,000 or something on the
lawsuit or he expects to if it if it gets dismissed.
I think if it's I think it was if it gets dismissed, he'll have
spent
And I don't think he thinks it's likely it's getting dismissed.
It's possible it gets dismissed, but I don't think it's likely.
Not including Yeah, not including the trial.
Um, a that's nothing to him. I don't think that's nothing, man.
I I had the numbers because obviously the guy used to chat with
me about stuff. I think it was somewhere around $500 an hour
is what he was getting paid. He was doing about 40 hours a month.
Like I don't think he wasn't making like
he wasn't making like crazy crazy money from from kick. Sorry,
not 40 hours, 40 hours a week. 160
about 16k a month.
Is that right? No, that's not right. Jesus.
About 80k a month. He probably made about a million dollars or
1.5 million between his uh with his whole kick contract somewhere
in there. Pixie won just for wasting his time, money, and sanity.
Well, I understand how some people think that, Auggie. I understand
how some people think that. I think
I would just say it was pretty obvious that it wasn't an open
shut case and settling would have been his best
like like when he was like, "Oh, it's totally insane for her
to ask like for some huge amount of money." While I agree with
that, like you know, the 15 million initial offer, which by the
way, they offered to negotiate down from that was probably never
happening, but the 200,000 I thought 200,000 was the sweet spot.
Like just pay her 200,000 and walk away. Destiny said he would
consider Gamba if his second YouTube appeal is rejected. Maybe
he was trolling.
I don't think he's trolling.
I don't think so. Call it law school. Okay, I can call it law
school. Pixie won simply by making Rose appear in the court filings
and admitting she was underage in those videos.
I mean,
dude, you'll never ever get through to that cult, though, bro.
The person I was talking to, the other thing they said, "What
did they say?" They're like, "Oh, I liked his There was like
a whole bunch of his explanations they they defended."
[__] I'm trying to think.
I don't know. The most annoying one was the one where they're
like, >> "Just tipped $5 >> for not filtering me
despite the drama." >> Okay. You're You're welcome.
Yeah. Although I will say you guys do just argue about Discord
in the kick chat as well, which is kind of annoying, but you're
welcome. I guess
just free KCIP money for me. Okay, how I see it. I don't know.
I see a lot of people in chat are like laughing over how
much this is [__] with Destiny.
I'm trying to think of like how I feel about it because he is
like a person. I wouldn't say I like want him with or I didn't
I don't know. It's hard to say now.
How much money are you making, Jay?
None of your goddamn business. SS SS SS SS SS SS SS SS SSS1.
None of your goddamn business. Sorry,
it's difficult to read your name. What's this KCIP stuff? People
chatting. It helps a great deal. Thank you. appreciate your patronage.
Appreciate it. Okay, we'll get back to this Connor conversation
real quick. I think we entertained the botting stuff. I don't
think I'll feel like justice is served
if
he's only if only civil penalties are imposed to be honest with
you.
Like I I just don't think I'll agree that justice has been served
if it's just civil penalties. So that's how I that's how I feel
about it. We'll we'll see what happens. Destiny literally brought
this all on himself. He did. That's maybe the worst part of this
is like the victimization, like the self victimization all the
time when like his reactions if he was that's
really the ultimate way to look at it. If he was who he pretended
to be like for the past 3 years or whatever, he would have come
out and said something along the lines of, "I really up. I violated
these people's trust. I'm going to take some time to myself.
I'm going to get some help. I'm going to come back and I will
make it up to you guys."
If he takes that path, I think he loses almost nobody. And to
be honest, he still loses me, but I Yeah, I don't know. I think
he doesn't lose as anywhere near the same amount of people.
Okay. Oh, man. The end of this conversation. This conversation.
I got to listen to this one day while I was driving. Not when
I was going to school, but uh or school. Not when I was going
home. Jesus. I don't know why I said school. Maybe I read it
somewhere. I don't know. Dyslexia.
Not when I was going home, but before that. I I listened to this
while I was driving and I was just like, dude, the the lies,
the just like bold, bald, whatever the term is, bold or bald-faced
lies that come out here are they're just staggering. They're
like
It's very funny. It's probably going to be fairly direct, fairly
brutal, and fairly easy to understand. I don't have like the
same type of I'll call it like snark communities uh that can
operate. Um, some
dude, there's just no way I in terms of like holding a standard
here. I'm really transforming this content, by the way, in terms
of maintaining a standard, right? There's just absolutely
no way that Destiny can disassociate from Dan weaponizing his
community against Hassan
when that's clearly like snark. That is clearly absolutely snark,
right?
Oh, wait. Is he here? That's Anyway, I'll finish the point first.
That's clearly like absolutely snark. And then I can be blamed
for like Kiwi Farms. There's just no possible way you can maintain
that standard. Yeah. Oh, hold on. What did he say?
Someone told me there's still cope in here that I was going to
there going to be criminal charges against me. I said I felt
justice wouldn't be served if you didn't get criminal charges,
but I don't know anything about that. So, we'll see. I'm not
even going to lose the civil case.
I mean, it sounded like you said you lost $850,000.
Maybe that's just not a problem. If it's if it's not that big
a deal, I suggest you stop acting like such a whiny about it.
If it is a big deal, then don't say you didn't lose. Damn, that's
crazy. Auggie be summoning this guy. What are you What are you
doing, Auggie? How did you summon this guy? Guy hasn't been here
in forever.
That's wild symmetrically with other like I guess I call them
snark communities like just whatever towards me. So it's very
easy for um them to play the quable deniability game on everything
and then for me obviously I just own anything that I do. So yeah
the perception is building to what you're saying the perception
is is that like oh wow like Destiny is being really unhinged
against this person and you can't prove that for instance like
they've done anything like unhinged towards him. So it comes
off as it can come off as disproportionate. Yeah, I like I understand
that. Yeah, I think that's definitely true. Yeah, for sure. >> Okay.
I mean that that was the main thrust of it to be honest and at
the at the risk of repeating myself. The the the way that JTO
or Dubbie or Quean or anybody who you've said like hey if these
people get docks that's based or whatever. Uh the whole thing
is they're appealing uh to almost like an individualist sense
of dignity culture which I do find sympathetic. I do think ideally
we would turn the other cheek. I do think ideally we would engage
in tit for tat. Um, however, they they're appealing to that sense
of dignity, whereas I think what you're kind of saying is like,
listen, man, like these people are doing barbaric barbaric to
me in a collective sense of maybe it's not Queenman, maybe it's
not JTO, maybe it's not um I can't think of the third person,
but effectively like the swatting, the doxing, the digital harassment,
the uh you know the the >> Does Destiny think that I said
he was going to lose his civil case? Did I ever I said you were
guilty of every element of the civil case with the exception
that there's no proof you actually fell within Cardi. That's
exactly how this is all played out the whole time. You're like
objectively guilty of every element of like the Cardi statute,
right? You you've fulfilled every element there. You just can't
be sued because there's no proof. Well, sorry. I was like you
might win because there might not be proof anymore that you sent
it to anyone else. That's literally all I said and it has to
go to Discovery. I also never said you were representing yourself.
I actually said people were for saying that. This guy's out of
his mind. You literally will never find a clip of me saying Destiny's
representing himself. Um, that's cuz I happen to speak to somebody
who told me exactly who your lawyers were. I'll give you one
clue. I'll give you one clue. I happen to know for a fact that
you had real lawyers.
Like literally just factually knew you had real lawyers.
So I never made the claim that you were representing yourself
because I just knew you weren't. Okay. So that's all. Wait, what?
What else did he say? Hold on. I missed it. Go post move from
he's representing himself as his lawyers are just wasting his
time money.
Uh, okay.
And now to Well, um, at least he had to spend money winning the
case.
I Nope.
You're literally just changing what my actual opinion was. I
said it was definitely worth it for you to settle, but okay.
Sad. The leaks, this that, the other. you're effectively at the
mercy of an army of digital schizophrenics and you don't really
have a clear way to punch back which is why you're doing what
you're doing or at least that's the steel man from my perspective
by the way I
like I feel I feel weird that this guy has this impression of
me when after everything I'm still sitting here going like no
I don't actually think he's bing no I don't like I don't know
if I just want him like heard in this case I think maybe justice
I I'll feel like justice has been served if he actually gets
like a criminal like charge of some kind and he comes in and
just goes on rant about something else.
>> Yeah, I do think there is an interesting phenomenon
though when it comes to um like ongoing harm. Um you would agree
that the like the punishment for punching somebody shouldn't
be execution, right? Like we shouldn't put somebody on death
row if they punched somebody, right? >> Right. Yeah. It
has to be proportional. >> Yeah. But let's say somebody
punched you and then let's say they said they were going to punch
you again and you took out a gun and you're like like stop or
I'm going to shoot like I don't care. I'm going to come. I'm
going to punch you again. Right. You might you argue, right?
in these circumstances, assuming it's not a 2-year-old child
or something, right? They're like, "Okay, well, you probably
could, you know, this person here. You could defend yourself
here, right?" >> Yeah. That's the basis of self-defense.
>> Yeah. So, I think um
uh I don't want to talk to the guy to be honest with you. I I
straight up don't want to. I If he wants to find clips, I already
said I didn't say those things that he was saying. Um, I thought
initially he was guilty of I think cyber harassment because you
could construct an attempt, but then I talked to some people
who were actual lawyers and they're like, "No, constructing this
intent is really difficult." So, I was like, "Oh, well, my bad.
I was wrong on that." Um, but that that maybe is it, but probably
from like about a month into the case, I was like, "Oh, no. I
I don't think that's like a strong case. I don't think it's like
guaranteed. It'll just come down to discovery." What do they
find in Discovery? It's an interesting world when we're talking
about like ongoing harms. I think that the calculation for like
what kind of retribution Oh, if Destiny is still watching though,
I don't know if he is, but if he were to still be watching, I
would just say the offer still stands. If you want to ban Darius,
who explicitly went to try to fight somebody based on an address
he doxed, you want to ban that guy, I'll ban Caiba. We can do
a trade one for one trade deal offer. Okay. It's not even really
retribution, but what kind of like action is justified on the
other end, I think, changes quite a bit, right? Like if I was
doing this in response to like stuff that they' done a long time
ago, I mean, one, I just wouldn't. I just don't have an attention
span for it. I don't care. Um, then I think that the argument
would be a lot different there. Um, and then two, if the other
party was looking for any type of reciprocation,
I think it would be different as well. But like, they're not
right. The other party denies the other parties basically deny
all wrongdoing, ascribed to me way more wrongdoing than any of
them I've ever been able to substantiate. Um, and then as a result
of both of these things,
is that true? I think he has recorded
encounters without consent. He's distributed them without consent
to multiple people. I think he has recorded with consent other
encounters that he he's distributed without those partners' consent.
Um I think that number is at four publicly.
I think at least five
uh I think at least five given like private conversations I've
had. But again, if those people never come out, you don't have
to take that seriously. You can just say the four that are public,
right? Stasia,
uh Molina,
Pixie, and
So, but I don't I don't think I like ever attributed more harm
or more wrongdoing to him than he actually did. >> Are
able to like indefinitely justify like a continued, you know,
real life harassment campaign. [laughter] Yeah, that I think
is a little bit unhinged. >> I don't think you should harass
Destiny in real life. Lauren de Lagura saying like his address
and that was totally unhinged. Totally disavow that. I don't
know why she would do that. I think you should harass this guy
in real life. But then the the possible deniability enters it
because we're we're treating these things I guess in this like
collective responsibility sense. We're treating them as tribes
where effectively if and I've heard you argue this in the past
because there's crosspollination between the snarker discords
and Kiwi Farms and Docspin and this that the other. Uh the people
who are constantly saying Steven's bad guy. He needs to get taken
down. He needs to be canceled. He's done all these evil. He's
going to do evil [__] in the future. [__]
him. Blah blah blah blah. that's ruin his >> to be clear.
I think when this all first came out before like his response,
I think I said like obviously you could withhold judgment. I
don't judge people who just want to but like probably
if you watch him as like a moral authority. If you're watching
him for political views and as a moral authority, you're deluding
yourself. But if you just watch him because he's like liberal
Ethan Ralph, then more power to you. Like you have my blessing.
I'm not going to say you can't do that. You know what I'm
And I didn't actually want him deplatformed in any way until
he started his doxing campaign. Then I'm like, "Oh, this guy's
actually like going crazy. He's doxing a bunch of people." Yeah,
I do think he should be deplatformed. I do think he shouldn't
be on YouTube at least. I I won't go after his kick because I
don't know what the rules are on kick, but on YouTube, I think
that's pretty like they'll they'll action off platform behavior
that's that severe. I think I think that's fair.
life. Uh even if they're saying that on stream and they're not
individually doxing you, harassing you, swatting you, etc. You're
going to hold them responsible for the outgrowth of that, which
is doc information, swatting, and harassment. And their argument,
>> well, a couple things. Yeah. So, firstly, um I no longer
buy this argument. I used to be I'm too charitable. I'm still
too charitable, really. But like, um I don't >> Dude, I
[laughter] I'm like too charitable. I'm like the most charitable
person, but I shouldn't be anymore. But I am still. And I can't
help it. But I shouldn't. But I am
dude, it's so it's like so it's perpetual. It's the perpetual
victimization motion machine. Okay,
>> I don't I no longer buy the argument of like my community
just happens to resemble one to one every single unhinged person
of this other community. Um I think the overlap is if not intentional
like every person in these communities is aware of it and they
are okay with it and supportive of it and they all like play
into it and feed into it. Um so like this idea that like oh we
just happen to be in some of the same places. I don't accept
that anymore. I think that's I think that's crazy. number one.
And then number two, my issue is not with people who are just
like critical of me or who speak up about me or whatever. Um
I like I know people like to present it that way because it it
underplays or downplays their actions and it makes me look insane.
Um it's people that are either fostering or hosting communities
or who are actively participating or encouraging what I would
consider to be some of the most insane like real life harassment
that you can basically get to up to like visiting me in real
life. So when you have you know like for Jessica Discord like
the easiest example point to recently and there are others too.
>> there aren't others. He's got like the cyber thing and
he way blows out of proportion. This >> Kelly can actually
talk about some of these. Um, but like when you're contacting
people that are part of my court case and you're shooting all
these emails on the Discord server, like everybody is giving
you thumbs ups over it. Like you know some >> to be clear
the I think the thumbs up were for the
aerodite thing and the aerodite conspiracy theory thing. I don't
know what you want from us.
I think we handled that incredibly responsibly. If we were actually
like Kiwi farmers when when we found out that not so Aerodite
went to a medieval like Renaissance fair that Rose also went
to they were there at the same time. What do you think Kiwi farmers
would do with that information? I think they would publicize
that information and try to make it look as bad for the people
involved as possible, right?
What did we do? We like kind of joked about it. We waited months
and then eventually it got like posted. I was like, "Hey, first
of all, we need to be clear. There's no evidence that this is
anything beyond a coincidence. It's a really weird coincidence,
but like it's just a coincidence. Do not take something serious
away from this. Don't bug Aridite about it's like right. I went
through on stream. I was like very careful about it. I didn't
say it meant anything. You know what I'm You know what I'm saying?
But when you're responsible with stuff, there's just nothing.
No, nobody ever goes like, "Oh, that's cool. That feels a little
insane to be coincidence." I know. But like I know it feels insane
to be coincidence. I know. Okay. I know. Wasn't that fair? Like
hundreds of miles out of the way for Kyla.
Yeah, but I still there's like I know I know people like just
go, >> dude. But still, like I promise you I understand
you want to connect patterns. Okay,
I understand. But I don't there's no reason to believe that that's
like a thing that has significant meaning.
You can hold on to it in your brain,
but I just don't think there's any reason to believe that. Like
what what would be the point? What would be the purpose? I don't
even know. Was it a really popular Renf fair? I think it was
the biggest Renaissance fair in like Nebraska or something. I
think it may it might have even been the biggest Renaissance
fair in the Midwest. So,
And also,
we found out about this publicly I want to say 8 months after
he started doxing people. And I mean, there's also just a ton
of other things here. Also, Cyba's like somebody who stuck around
in this community after being in his community, right? Cyber
was in his community for a very long time.
Zab was a subscriber of his for years and years and years. Took
like a lot of people like that around. >> Tried to wheel
this one out. Oh well post talk rationalizing this like that
didn't happen until later and it's like no this is one action
in a long chain of actions but it's hard to point to the other
ones in particular because of how you know they do try to ban
the outright stuff but it says something. >> So they do
what's in their power.
All they're willing to do is the things they're capable of doing.
And I think that'sed up
all they're not even willing to ban people on Kiwi farms. Well
unfortunately I'm not null. I don't have the ability to do that.
If I had the ability to do that, maybe I'd think about it, but
I don't. It would probably be the end of Kiwi Farms. I don't
know if that would be a bad thing or not, but
you know, most the other threads most the other threads aren't
that bad. Maybe something about >> I don't really use it
enough to know to be honest with you. >> Your community,
if every single person in your community is like totally fine
with that and is jumping on board with that, it's probably not
the first time they've done it. This probably has been, as I've
said, like a long history of like this.
>> Dude, I wish my community was totally fine. I wish I
had a sickopantic community.
We just had an argument like 2 days ago.
Literally, I My parents went to sleep at like 10 p.m. on Christmas
or Christmas Eve maybe. And then we had a whole discussion in
uh we had a whole discussion about it. People were mad about
it. People are real mad about it, but like we talk about it,
this type of behavior. Yeah. Well, so then the the example though
is kind of the
uh the counter example that I've heard brought up is as
Rose allegedly, right? And if you don't want to get into specifics,
we don't have to get >> so whatever you want. It's all
public >> But the but but effectively that like Rose like
early in the court case, at least as far as I understand it,
we didn't know the difference between Rose and Solo. You didn't
necessarily have any more cont. >> Okay, hold on. I'm going
to back it up two seconds cuz I use the bathroom really quickly
and I don't want to miss stuff. So, I'm going to back it up.
I'll be right back.
it's probably not the first time they've done it. It's probably
has been, as I've said, like a long history of like this type
of behavior. Yeah. >> Well, so then the the example though
is kind of the
uh the counter example that I've heard brought up is as uh is
that Rose allegedly, right? And if you want to get into specifics,
we don't have to get whatever you want. It's all public filings
now. But the but but effectively that like Rose like early in
the court case, at least as far as I understand it, we didn't
know the difference between Rose and Solo, you didn't necessarily
have any more contact with Rose. And so uh docking her information
or putting her information out there so she could be found was
in their opinion a barbaric retributive action because you didn't
know whether or not Rose was an innocent party. >> Yeah.
But like that, to be clear, I I understand that's not a good
faith argument. Nobody really believes that, right? that me looking
for this person who I have no >> nobody really believes
when I like explicitly taunted Kiwi Farms with this person's
like doc information with part with PII that would lead to her
being doxed directly. Nobody really believes that I did that
maliciously, right? Like that I can't find this person
It's malicious if I try to find this person. It's like well wait
I thought your whole thing was that like Kiwi Farms is bad. Isn't
your whole thing that Kiwi Farms is bad? What did you think they
were going to do if they found this person? like, "Okay, go."
And I think he apparently shows Connor that he hired a private
investigator. I
kind of sincerely doubt that with like Really made this point
with her face, her name, and her major.
How the [__] do you not find this person? Oh, wait,
maybe not the name. With her face and her major and her school.
Is it really that hard to find the person?
Like literally if you paid a private investigator to go to the
place.
It should be fairly easy to find them. >> No idea. I don't
have any lead on who leaked any. Oh, also I would want proof
that Destiny sent the same information that he gave to Kiwi Farms
to the PI. Probably right. If he were to hire a private investigator,
did you give them the same leg up you gave to Kiwi Farms? >> Thing
I don't know what the only thing I know is the Rose person that
I spoke to that Solo allegedly said just gave her his account.
I don't know. I don't know the time that was necessarily true
or not, but I have nothing to go on for somebody who has, I would
say, pretty egregiously, probably in a partial way than anybody
in the history of my entire life has like aggressed on me. I
think I'm kind of within my rights there to do whatever I can
to try to find this person. I think that that's I think that
>> Okay. Within your rights, but then the the path of least
harm would be like hiring a PI, right?
>> Um,
yes. Wait, hold on. Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. Can you
hold Wait, wait, wait. Can you can you um can you send me a uh
Are we texting or whatever? are I mean, >> have we ever
before? Oh, wait. Hold on.
>> Or actually, wait,
give me one second. >> If you don't want to get into specifics,
we don't have to get into specifics. >> No, we can get
into anything you want. Um, it's annoying because another thing
I'm only doing this because I'm talking to you, okay? Cuz these
guys these people don't care about like the facts on literally
any of this. One sec. >> I do care about the facts. Love
facts. >> I'm trying to think about what this um I like
I did hire a private investigator and they couldn't find anything.
Uh, but no, dude, Jessica, nobody believes I talk about any of
this [__] Oh, here. I don't think I don't think there's
a level of I'm trying to find this person, so I'm going to put
all a bunch of docs information out into the open and hope that
Kiwi Farms can find her. I don't think that's a valid path to
take ever,
right? Like probably the argument is just that's never the, you
know, my Kiwi, this is Destiny's mindset. Um, well, I tried a
private investigator and they ghosted me. So now I can go and
give it to my Kiwi Farms thread. the people I say are the most
evil people on planet Earth. It's like [laughter] although to
be fair,
it worked [laughter]
and that person got harassed and obviously Destiny has a lot
of he's complicit in that harassment in a lot of ways, right?
Since he is the reason that she was found,
but
so I just we'll listen to this. We'll see what he says about
the private investigator. I get the sense that this investigator
was not somebody who made a serious effort to find her. Um, I
just I just want to send you a [__] like this. They
they basically ended up ghosting me after I paid for the service
here. Hold on. Boom. Boom. Boom. And I asked both my law firms
to look for this person and neither one was able to locate them.
I just want to send you this just so that [__] somebody
sees this cuz the same stupid [__] gets repeated
over and over again. Right.
>> But this is good. I know other people. >> No,
you don't. I don't care if you do. But I just seen I've sent
you like this is my um Oh, wait. Did I send that to you or did
I send it to myself?
Oh, wait, wait, hold on. >> Yeah, I'm waiting for the language
on this so we could see. >> Um, I'm coming, Paul. Hold
on. Here you go. Okay. You see this, right?
>> Uh, give me one second. I'm going to move you off screen.
That way I don't expose all our other private messages and I'm
going to look at it on my phone. So, give me give me a second
real quick. I I just want to make sure that I don't actually
uh expose our other messages our other private messages. True.
All
>> Okay. Yep. I see it. >> Just verifying that. Yeah.
Okay. >> And I also see the date. >> Yeah. Oh, long
time ago, right? >> Yeah. Yep. Okay. True. I didn't think
Yeah. So, yeah. So, I did try to do this. I know that reason
I didn't all because but like no you heard me talk to D no matter
what I say like these people aren't interested in the >> when
did he wait when did he hire this person and then what did he
give them for information >> truth they have their idea
about me being some you know whatever crazy abuser trying to
this girl or whatever
>> yeah if I could just articulate for that chat without
you know saying anything specific um effectively I see the date
I see the time and
>> should have just hired Saiba to be Cyber didn't find
Rose. Cyber didn't like figure out who Rose was. It was after
it was made public like everywhere who this person was that Cyber
was like, "Hey, you got doxed
to be super clear."
>> And I see some communications at what looks like hiring
a private investigator with things that I would expect out of
hiring a private investigator. >> Yep. Which is also why
I was annoyed when Pixie put in her filings that um they spent
money to hire a private investigator to find this girl. They
didn't. They just got it from Kiwi Farms. And now I know that
because it was the person from justical server that emailed um
them and then um threatened basically the girl to get her to
email Joan as well. So yeah, >> I just wish Connor would
ask for like substantiation of the threat. What was the threat
here?
Like people people tell me you shouldn't even bite the bullet
that this is weird. I I don't care about calling it weird. Weird
is the weasel word you use when you don't want to say something's
morally wrong because you know you can't really make that argument,
right? But like threaten that's just objectively not happening
He's learned not to ask questions like that. I do believe he
would get in trouble for asking questions like that. It is It
is frustrating to me. I I messaged Connor after this and I'm
just like, is there like a reason you don't ask follow-ups like
ever when you're talking to Destiny? Like I and I I was nice.
I but it's just it's like a little frustrating to me when I listen,
right? And I'm like, dude, is there a reason that you like I
think there are very reasonable follow-ups to some of these things.
like he Destiny will say something happened or say like an allegation
about me or my community and if I say things like that to Connor,
Connor says, "Could you substantiate that?" But when I But when
Destiny says it to Connor, Connor basically just moves forward,
which like, okay, I get it. It's difficult to have, you know,
he probably feels some sort of financial alignment here. It's
a difficult conversation to have, but like come on, >> Well,
okay. So what I want to say though which you know is saying this
as a uh online and slightly IRL friend of 5 years now. So I guess
the reason why like I know that you're pulled between many forces
at all times and as an example people want you to have a schizophrenic
personal life because it's entertaining. It's entertaining. It's
fun to talk about uh whenever something pops off. I mean I'm
guilty of it too. We call it the uh the Destiny watching traffic
helicopter because the easiest way to get a few hundred live
viewers is to cover uh personal drama, you know, in your life,
right? >> And and uh it's an easy way to make money. It's
an easy way to get a larger
>> but you know, as your online friend, I don't want to
see you hurting yourself for the entertainment of the chat. >> Yeah.
And >> Oh, wait, wrong point. I don't I don't think this
is what I was talking about. >> And to be clear, I'll reiterate
this for the billionth time. Although I don't think you believe
me, but my audience knows that my personal life has been pretty
divorced from my stream for like the past two years. It's been
>> Hold on. Why I'm not on the right page on my soundboard?
It's a red bar moment. Are we serious right now? Yeah. The previous
two years. So like for one thing, for one thing, yes. For one
thing, yes.
But, uh, the whole Pixie thing, he'll argue the Pixie thing is
like going back from before this. And then,
uh, what else is there? We're still within the two-year limit
of he was having this whole fight with Lab and Zoey in my community
less than two years ago. Now, it's coming up. It's getting close
to two years on that one, but it was less than two years ago
when that fight was happening, right?
So, like the Merc thing was almost exactly one year ago, Tequila
Sunset where he came and he was fighting about his personal life
on stream a year ago, right? It was like a year and 20 days
Yeah. The Day Laguna stuff is getting like he threw that up on
his stream like
like Connor has to feel a little talked down to a little like
he's getting like gas lit super hard here, right? Like
Connor's so he's got to be so close to just being like dude could
you like make your lies a little less like you're making me look
like an actual [__] right now. Like you're treating
me like I'm a total [__] It's Yeah. And also wait
also he's covering his case's court drama on stream all the time.
Wait
now maybe you say that's the difference between he's talking
about life or something versus private life. But he's literally
talking about his court case on stream all the time. Was Molina
two years ago? Molina was like three years ago, I think. I think
it's like three years ago. Christmas time is when they broke
up. 2023.
Yeah.
2022, I think. I think.
Dude, it But it is like like he Connor has to sit here and he
can't go, "Wait, I can talk about your personal life drama because
of you putting like statements out constantly still. What are
you talking about? You don't do your personal life
Bro, you like play video games and litigate your case on stream.
Those are like the things you do. What are we talking about?
Do we count as Nathan as public? No. And I'm trying to maintain
that line as it feels. Okay. Cuz there's there's two things here.
Okay. One of them is you can criticize somebody's parenting without
being without you know people will say, "Oh, don't talk about
my kids." But you can criticize somebody's parenting without
talking [__] about their kids. I try to keep it clear
that because I'm aware that
his kid engages in the space and I don't want to affect that
relationship
even though I shouldn't give a [__] I don't want
to. So, I try to keep my comments I try to keep my comments sparse.
I will say, okay, I have to do one joke. Okay, I have to do one
joke. No, I can't I can't do it. I can't do it. I I can't do
it. I can't do it. I'm sorry. I can't do it.
I can't do it. I can't do the one joke. I I'm constantly >> less
than it ever was.
>> I I can't do the >> in the past. But yeah, go
ahead.
>> Well, in but but then what I was going to say in reference
to that personal life is divorced from the stream. I want that
to continue, I suppose. Yeah. >> But then the >> Yeah.
But then also in reference to dealing with these anti-fan communities,
if we're talking about you participating in barbarian retributed
violence, I mean, maybe that we can envision an enemy that To
be clear, I wouldn't consider what I'm doing barbarian, whatever.
I I think it's pretty I think it's pretty eye for an eye in terms
of
>> Okay. Well, the however we if we want to class it eye
for an eye, I think that your critics are categorizing it as
barbarian retributed violence. But regardless of what it is,
>> u some >> man, I bet you I bet you I could have
actually liked Arc Raiders. I associate it with like that community
now. I'll never look into a game. I'll never play the game.
It feels like I just like I hear the name and I'm like gh like
there's just like a mental attach that there's like a mental
connection that goes on in my head and I hear like somebody talk
about the game and I'm like gh it's just like it's it's that
um
oh what is it Wes described it. It's like uh food you like do
this like food disgust thing where you like tie the things in
your brain like a certain food will become gross to you. That's
what's happened with like Arc Raiders. I'm like, uh, I just I
hear the name and I'm like, gh,
it sucks. >> Sometimes barbarian retributive violence could
be justified, right? Because if there was, let's say that we're
barbarians and this is like caveman days. Let's say that there
is an aggressive tribe that continues to attack you. Well, if
you keep doing reciprocative penalties
and they keep
>> Reuben donated $3, would you ever play
Um, probably not, but maybe not for the same reason >> to
take you out. Then all you're doing is you're tolerating somebody
who wants
>> And so, although I will say, let let me like let me
just say this, like one of the things that I look for when I'm
seeing like how true a person's claims are, especially when it
comes to like fear, is I'm looking at how the person is behaving
or acting. And >> dude, this is the crazy thing. Um, if
you were actually if you cared about getting doxed when I threatened
you with doxing, you'd stop doing whatever you were doing. I
said I was going to dox you and you need to stop doing that or
else you're not scared of it. And I hear this thing a lot brought
up about like DGG and how terrifying my community is and all
this. And I think my community is basically terrifying if you're
like a friend of mine because then you care about what my community
thinks and if you say something they disagree with their and
their hate thread is like way more aggressive than it needs to
be.
um your community is terrifying or was terrifying, maybe it's
less so now because of the narrative shaping they do, right?
That whatever you tell them, they will go and there are a lot
of them still, they will spread whatever narrative you say is
true on Twitter and when you don't like somebody, that narrative
will be insanely negative about them. And we've watched this
happen with Max, with Lav, with me to some extent, right? That's
what's actually terrifying is these people will go around and
they are like missionaries. They'll go to other chats and be
like, "This guy sucks. This guy s this person's a liar. This
person's evil. This person sucks." Right?
And I think what Destiny doesn't like about this so-called like
snark community, I I'll call it what it is, the the snarkle left
community that sort of goes to chats and talks him, is he probably
sees the mirror image of DG,
right? He understands how important he thinks those things are.
That's that's what people are actually scared of. They're not
scared of real life harassment. People say they're scared of
DGG. They don't mean like, "Oh, that person's going to come to
my house and kill me." I will say for me that is a low-level
concern, but it is a concern when Destiny says this person should
be and also tries to dox me. Okay, that's that's just fine. Like,
sorry, [clears throat] that's just fair.
Like, it's not I don't think there's a high probability of it
happening. There's a low probability, but it's very real. Becomes
very real when he talks about it, right?
But it's the narrative shaping online and how they will go and
they'll be in other communities, right? These people are all
in like two or three other adjacent communities and Destiny understands
that when those people go to other communities and they say the
same negative things that those things tend to stick over time
regardless of how true they are. Right. It's reasonable to be
scared of doxing. Yeah, absolutely it is. And I I I don't think
it's reasonable to say you're not scared of doxing. But I'm saying
the reason people consider his community scary is not necessarily
because they were they don't have a reputation of doxing from
before Destiny started doxing people. I don't think they had
a reputation of that. Their reputation was like narrative shaping
in a negative way about anybody you dislike.
Right? About
Vos about your ex-wife about basically anybody about
about anybody you don't like Mr. girl laugh. Um, anybody you've
who's like negatively come out against you, that's what they
actually are scared of. They don't want those people going around
lying about them everywhere on the internet in case they want
to exist on the internet. That's just that's how it is, man.
That's sorry. That's how it was. Now, I think people do have
every right to be scared of doxing. I think that's why Pisco
probably made the rule about his Discord where he doesn't want
that stuff discussed because it seemed like Destiny was just
like saying this guy's a target now, which is crazy. All right,
I I'm can be like even less scared about doxing than most people
cuz I live in
Like I said, I walk outside and there's like tundra in every
direction. Okay, you're coming to my place. Good luck. This is
This is like a military installation.
All right, Tundra, as far as the eye can see in every direction.
You can't sneak up on me. Okay, it's
So, like, but but other people live I think Pisco is pretty public
that he lives in New York, right?
Like, he's pretty public about it. Like, that's a city where
I would be scared of my doc's information being out there, right?
I would be I would be terrified of that because there's just
so many people that you you never know when one could be like
a crazy lunat you could crazy lunatic kind of a saying the same
thing twice but total lunatic right so I I think it's like scarier
for other people there's at least something there where for me
it's like not quite as
you know okay anyway yeah we had a >> but that's back it
up let me back it up just how terrifying my community is and
all this and I think my community is basically terrifying if
you're like a friend of mine because then you care about what
my community thinks and if you say something they disagree with
they're and their hate thread is like
well I think it is it is a violation to have the privacy thing
like you know we're gone and whatever but I I'm talking about
physical safety I think the concern with DGG is the the lying
to like reputation
that's like what people are more concerned about I think that's
a valid concern and when You pair that with the doxing, it becomes
like way way scarier, right? Like this community that's known
as like total reputation assassins. They will lie. They will
say anything about anybody to ruin their reputation online. And
then you pair that with doxing where like it's tied to somebody's
real name potentially. Like that's terrifying for everybody.
There's literally not a single person on planet Earth that's
not terrifying for.
So you take the past reputation, you add it to the current reputation.
Yeah, everybody's steering clear. Makes sense. But they will
send Darius to do physical harm. Well, I think the thing is for
me is like Darius did do that. And that was why I think most
of all that I said what Cyber did was wrong is because I don't
want that to be something that I like green light at all in my
community. Not even that I think like I'm not talking about whether
or not what he did was wrong. I don't want people from my community
trying to interact in any way because I don't want there to be
their judgment.
Like all that would be happening there is it's like I'm trust
I would be trusting their judgment on what a situation is. That's
why you have to disavow that and say it's not good, right? And
say like I don't want that. It's not to say I'm not responsible
or because Destiny is responsible. He'll say, "Oh, I'm not responsible
for Darius." It's like off. But
you just don't want anybody to sort of feel like they can do
those things and interact or exist in your community. That's
why I've said with the cyber thing, any more evidence of things
like this coming out in the future, you are just gone. There
won't be a discussion. There won't be anything like this, right?
They're just gone. There's no there's no ask. There's just nothing.
Cuz I never want to be blamed for people thinking like this is
acceptable. It's not.
Right. Anyway, uh where else are we going here? We >> Way
more aggressive than it needs to be. But that's about the extent
of of terrifyingness that my community goes to. And when I asked
Dubie, you know, what's an example of my community like real
life harassing somebody? The only example he could give me was
Darius apparently going to the wrong house for Riyal kidnaps.
Um, and Darius's does his own. Did he know he's going to the
wrong house? I'd say with that one, like what was the intent
there? Cuz hold on, I'll ask Riyle. Can I show that clip
cuz I could maybe show this. I just I don't know what's in the
clip exactly. Um, so I haven't ever shown it. I ask like Ry if
I can show that clip. I don't know if he's around right now.
Um cuz Darius did go and I believe that Darius did did say that
he was going to like try to fight. Yeah, sure. Uh we'll we'll
watch a little bit more and I think we're going to edit it down.
And then he had a video of Darius walking up to Lauren Deaguno
on the street and talking to her for 30 seconds.
And then when I look at like the behavior of the other communities,
well, it seems like all of them still spam talk about me. All
of them were still spamming streams on me. All of >> this
is this is the thing that upsets him, right? and I I react to
what he does for the reputation ruination stuff, but I do try
to move away from this stuff when I can. I'll be honest, tonight
I just didn't have other content, so I decided to go react to
all of his stuff, even though I kind of wanted to just go prepare
something so I could have things like the rile clip ready to
go, but I straight up didn't prepare content for tonight. So,
I was like, "Ah, it we go. We go. We do it. We do it live, I
guess." But yeah, he's like, "Oh, don't talk about me." It's
like, dude, are you serious? That's really the thing is he hates
that people have accurate negative opinions of him.
That's what he dislikes is that there are people with accurate
negative opinions of him in a community that is sort of isolated
from his and is going to like on him. He's talking about you.
Why shouldn't you talk about him? That's his logic. Well, he's
talking about my community in most cases. You you you'll find
this very obvious as you go through some of this stuff that criticisms
of my conduct or behavior are shockingly sparse. Like people
don't have criticisms of my conduct except hey I like let my
community talk you. And there are people who Destiny has tried
to dox people whose consent Destiny has violated. There are people
of all kinds in my community who I think have the right to go
somewhere and just be like this guy's a total piece of and I'm
never going to moderate that. I don't I don't like well I have
for the past little while kind of piled on this because he's
been explicitly like trying to dox people and actually doxing
people in my community. So now I am like piling on but for a
long time I I was more like concerned with doing the commentary
thing right uh we pointed this out tonight so neck like
again this was uh what Destiny interrupted me when he first came
into the chat earlier tonight. I was just talking about how he
when he's talking to Pisco, he says like, "Oh, I'm not responsible
for Dan." It's like, "Wait, why am I responsible for my community,
right? Why why am I responsible for my community or people around
me, but Destiny is not responsible for his business partner and
best friend who used Destiny's community, weaponized Destiny's
community against Hassan to try to get him deplatformed? I think
people have real problems with you. Either they're valid or not.
I don't know what that means, but if you want to elaborate, I'd
listen. Yeah. Yeah. I I don't know how he tries to say he's not
responsible for Dan or like Dan does his own thing. It's like
but Dan you explicitly know that Dan does this. I want to say
there's a quote somewhere of
did Dan say or did Destiny say like don't use my community for
or like stop [gasps] there there is somewhere where he's acknowledged
that Dan uses his community. He's also saying he's not responsible
for Darius in the clip. He does his own thing. Oh, been talking
to her for 30 seconds. Just >> um and then when I look
at like the behavior of the other communities, well, it seems
like, >> oh, well, I didn't hear him say Darius does his
own thing yet. But yes, when he says stuff like that, it's like,
okay, Darius does his own thing, but he's going to the address
you do. You're literally responsible here. You have a direct
causal link on this conduct happening. Like, you have you are
but for your doxing. This doesn't happen. Destiny would miss
your girl Dan if he actually cared. He isn't doing his own thing.
Um, I get the impression that Dan probably just knows some stuff
about Destiny that makes it difficult for Destiny to do anything
like that. >> like all of them still spam talk about me.
All of them were still spamming streams on me. All of them were
still cross-osting emails that that Saba guy was sending to my
attorneys to opposing council attorneys.
All of them were cross-osting those emails. I thought these emails
were like proof of my community's guilty conduct. Why would somebody
be cross-osting them? was somebody like cross posting them and
go this is awesome
if that was happening I'm unaware
to um victims in my case like all of this stuff it doesn't seem
like there's much fear on their side it doesn't seem like they're
really that afraid despite how horrifying you know the docs and
everything else is whereas when I look on my side right everybody's
terrified of the anti-fan communities over there hutch came out
and said like I can't like I can't be anywhere near you know
like again to be clear Hutch was doxed by Kiwi Farms in September
of
He's blaming my community, which was explicitly a Destiny fan
community when it started. It was like a Destiny super fan community
with like Destiny's friends in it. All of Destiny's like group
chat members were in it,
right? Oh, also the other thing, man, with regard, dude, I need
to write this stuff out. This is why I wanted to prepare.
So, when Hutch was doxed, I was a fan. And by the way, I agree.
I already said I explicitly avoided going on anything else because
I was like, "Dude, I'm I don't want to I don't want to face reveal
when Kiwi Farms is doxing people like this. It seems like insane
to do.
It seems totally crazy to try to do right now." Uh let's see.
>> Like Destiny with these guys, like the the doxing and
everything else that is going on this is just way way too crazy.
Like every >> Bro, I literally left yours in Pisco's Discords
with 10 messages because I didn't want to be part of some Max
Docs. Sorry about that. Uh yeah, I get it. I get why people would
leave. It's just like when when I think when Destiny's doing
that, I do think at that point it crosses into like this is offplatform
conduct that something like YouTube would moderate. I do believe
Discord would moderate it as well. Uh I think it's like difficult
to actually report things to Discord. And again, I'm reporting
Destiny. Like if I were to report Destiny, it would be for his
direct conduct. It wouldn't be for like, well, I think that somebody
who's adjacent to him, somebody who's adjacent to someone who's
adjacent to him is doing bad things. It wouldn't be like that,
right? It would be, "Oh, here's him like explicitly posting doxes."
Yeah. You have does something and he lies that it's you and Quean.
Then these morons believe it for some reason. Destiny was the
reason they were doxed. Sadly. Yeah. And I like I don't think
it's like probably what Destiny should have been doing is letting
people know that he had like a community of people who really
disliked him, who really would go after anybody who appeared
on stream. Like for me,
was the one who posted the original PV doc's on his article,
right? This is this is the case. Lingre was the one who originally
posted, but he did eventually go edit and like put a layer of
indirection there and then Kiwi Farms posted them after Lingre
had posted them, I believe, as well. I don't know if it's directly
connected or not. Uh, hold on. This is this is what I try to
tell people. Snognik is like it all comes down to like one guy
that Destiny hated that Destiny's had like a fight with going
on like as an undercurrent of his stream for years since this
guy figured out that Destiny was Lauren
right? That's basically what I I think that's what started their
like rivalry as it were. This guy figured out that Destiny was
from Lauren Southern. And then Destiny hated this guy and started
having like actual ego contests with him, either directly responding
to him in DMs or referencing him on stream or doing things to
with him on stream and then saying that he was doing them to
with him on stream, talking about his haters. Anytime Destiny
was talking about like, oh, you know, my haters say this about
me. What he means is Blav says this about me. Blav says that
about me. Blav says this about me. How did the fight with Blav
start? Uh, I don't know why Blav was paying that closer to class
of attention to Destiny. I just remember it was the Lauren Southern
thing. I think that's the first time I ever went to Kiwi Farms
was somebody in DG chat linked it to me. I was like, "Hey, do
you see this Lauren Southern thing?"
I was like, "Oh, that's crazy. [__] this place?"
I I'm pretty sure I It's possible there was something before
that, but I think that's the first time I ever like actually
looked at anything on there. How come there's no screen caps
of these things, man? Wait, what are you talking about, Maximus?
You talk about the Blav Lauren Southern thing. I think there
are screen caps if you go look at like Queenman did a video on
it. Um
Queman Lauren
Southern Destiny sickening messages revealed. Not this one. By
the way, this is one of the things people um
I've been talking to certain people. Actual Djers DMing me. Okay.
Like you you you read his on stream. I'm like actually I explicitly
avoided doing that. Uh, this Renor guy says, "Blad was a Destiny
fan who hated Molina so much that he realized Destiny was cheating
on her with Lauren Southern and obsessively started tracking
it." Okay,
what really happened? Destiny's worst kept secret Lauren Southern
connection. >> There's been a lot of discussion recently
surrounding the rumors about Destiny and Lauren Sullivan's relationship,
mainly coming from two
>> Queen better thank his lucky stars that he ended up
making it as a streamer cuz this sucks at editing. Okay, I'll
just be real with you guys. He [__] sucks at editing.
>> First, Andrew Wilson of the Crucible, also known as
Big Papa Fascist, brought the rumors up to Destiny during a debate
on the Playing with Fire channel. This resulted in Erodite, who
because of her closeness with Destiny,
There's one other Hold on. There's one other commentary video
he made. This one, by the way, was reasonably well done from
a narrative perspective. It's actually just the the cuts, this
this like intermission screen. I don't like the Woo one is good.
The Woo one's pretty good. Was like 15 here. It was 2 years ago.
No, he was like 31 here. What is he 27 now or something? I think
he's be 25 on this one. 24 25. Anyway, yeah, he figured out he
figured out a cadence that makes him not sound quite soy. Every
single person in my corner of the internet was getting doxed
on KB farms and everybody was getting crazy harassed by the people
in Justic's Discord server. So like
everyone was getting crazy harassed by the people in Justicle's
Discord server. Like do you see how he just sneaks that in that
thing that didn't happen
of the anti-fan communities over there? Hutch came out and said
like I can't like I can't be anywhere near you know like Destiny
with these guys like the the doxing and everything else that
was going on. This is just way way too crazy. Like every single
person in my corner of the internet was getting doxed on KB farms
and everybody was getting crazy harassed by the people in just
Discord server. So like I don't buy into that. I don't think
they even >> it's what is the timeline
like all of this stuff. It doesn't seem like there's much fear
on their side. It doesn't seem like they're really that afraid
despite how horrifying you know the docs and everything else
is. Whereas when I look on my side, right, everybody's terrified
of the anti-fan communities over there. Hutch came out and said
like, "I can't like I can't be anywhere near, you know, like
again, Hutch was told by somebody, somebody lied to Hutch and
said like, "Look, they're doxing you here." And it's a lie by
omission because he leaves out that you were doxed on this website
like a year before this or something. Okay. Okay.
Sorry, I'm getting more links here. Um, yeah, you're you're doxed
in like September 2024. And Destiny reads the Kiwi Farms thread
of him obsessively
and any claims otherwise are just like totally total lies. He
reads it obsessively. He would constantly reference it on stream
like years ago. He uh, [__] what am I trying to think
of? Oh, he never informs people. And he really should. He should
inform his friends like, "Hey, I have this like pretty crazy
thing. you should make sure your like opsec is good cuz if if
we're collabing I have like this other element here right but
he doesn't do that cuz that like actually with people might go
well actually maybe I don't want to collab maybe I don't want
to be on stream or something right
we're back to this counterpoints conversation now destiny with
these guys like the the doxing and everything else that was going
on this is just way way way too crazy like every single person
in my corner of the internet was getting doxed on KB farms and
everybody was getting crazy harassed by the people in justical
discord server so like >> yeah so the doxing thing again.
Um, and again, Destiny can try to make this different, but all
of the people he's talking about, how do I do this? How do I
separate this? Um,
I don't know how I separate this. Huh? I still don't know how
to talk about it cuz I don't want to just point out that like,
oh, all these people were docked. But basically, anybody who
is a big I'll look, okay, anybody around Destiny who's even a
like a big or medium-sized content creator was doxed either months
after he started his doxing campaign or months before like before
I like when I was his friend or like a content creator who managed
like a space that was adjacent to his, however you want to describe
that. He's doing the Keville's webbing thing. Yeah, we point
that out all the time. Spudgun, he is doing that, right?
Are you trying to say people were docked on both sides? No, I
am saying that there literally when Destiny decided to hold me
or Queenman or these communities responsible, there literally
wasn't doxing occurring
during that period. The closest you get there, I believe, is
a comment from somebody going, "Isn't this Tom Foolery guy just
goes LCO?" But do you feel communities that didn't like him were
adding fuel to the fire? Um, possibly.
But what what do you expect? What's the there? OMG, it's OG.
What do you think the odd is there? What ought we do if we have
legitimate claims, legitimate problems,
there isn't doxing occurring
and we want to describe those things because I would say that
I don't antagonize Kiwi Farms. I don't try to go and like with
Kiwi Farms. Destiny explicitly fights with them. Explicitly fights
with the people there. That's what he was doing in May of 2025
when he posted Rose's pictures, her her college, basically her
location and her major in that college.
Destiny explicitly taunts Kiwi Farms and taunts them into doxing
people
and then he expects me to not criticize him or not criticize
him um multiple times in the same month or something or like
they're basically their argument is like you go too hard. It's
like, well, I don't the content I think deceptively looks like
on the YouTube channel, like I go really hard on this guy, right?
Like I'm only covering him. I admit that that it can look like
that, but objectively the stuff that gets posted to the YouTube
channel, especially before maybe a month or two ago,
it was basically cutting just the Destiny like content. Like
Riyle was just trying to make money um for his channel, right?
So he would cut the stuff that was of interest to him, the Destiny
stuff.
Like I I understand that. I can't tell the guy, "Oh, you have
to go cut my like Candace Owens segment because I want that on
your YouTube channel." I can't tell him that, right? Even though
I did and I think Riyle refined his process. He got things like
going out a lot faster now. So, he puts a lot more stuff on there.
But before I just like it wasn't I would cover a bunch of stuff
on stream which wasn't indicative like the Riyle channel wasn't
indicative of the stuff I covered on stream like the uh
It's your content though. Uh it is my content but I don't think
so. I think if maybe if I was only covering Destiny every stream
for months and months and months, then I would understand. But
it's not like that. It's not like the Jaden McNeel stream with
Nick Fuentes with regards to Nick, right? It's not like that.
It's like really like mostly other content. Especially there
were long periods where we basically didn't talk about this guy
at all. Why didn't you apply to be Nick Lee's assistant? Because
I wouldn't want to do that.
So I stand by the content. I'm saying that the criticism they
make sometimes is, oh, it's only Destiny. It's like, no, it's
not. It's like actually been long periods of like no Destiny
content
or like I'll be waiting for a court document or something. Anyway,
anyway, so I'm saying that that criticism isn't really even an
accurate criticism. So, um,
at least from a guy who honestly likes you both, it felt like
an allout war between a ton of you guys. For a while, it felt
like there were no rules. Like, do or say whatever makes you
look good, your side win or look good. Can you name an example
of somewhere I lied? That would be helpful if you could say like
where I lied. So I understand that you could have that feeling,
but could you give me So you don't even need a clip, but could
you try to give me an example where I was like lying about Destiny
to get him? Like Like I I actually don't know.
I I literally don't know. So this is the thing is I always ask
people for examples cuz the most common examples that they use
are things that I explicitly was on the other side of like saying
that Destiny didn't have
I was explicitly on the other side of that saying no because
I literally knew for a fact that he had a lawyer. I knew his
lawyer's name before it was announced publicly. I knew that Andrew
Breler was this lawyer. I'm watching about an hour back. Did
you say Pixie offered to settle for 200k and dusty refused? Really?
No. Uh I don't know if you're watching this now or maybe you'll
catch up to it, but no, I did not say that. I said Pixie was
willing to settle for less than what she initially offered, which
is like the 15 million. I do believe they said we would explicitly
settle for less than that. and Destiny didn't give them like
a compelling return offer. The return offer was um you can keep
your Substack money and you give me an apology and you take down
your Substack. So, she didn't offer to settle for 200k as far
as I know. I think I said I thought the sweet spot this my feeling
was the sweet spot was about 200k about enough to pay for her
law school. I think 568 viewers with this chat speed. Hm. Get
the chatbot
Um do we have 568 viewers right now? That's crazy. 584. What?
>> Yeah, they're the people who moved into a Discord and
they were your friends and then they just spent months saying
you're a bad guy. >> That So when Blav doxed them initially,
>> that's one framing. Another framing is uh they didn't
like that they got doxed for being on your side of some drama.
That did happen. I felt bad for them. I deleted all their messages.
I did whatever I could to help them clean up anything from my
Discord cuz I felt really bad that they got doxed based on some
drama that happened on my stream. Wait, when I was still friends
with Destiny, by the way, I felt really bad about this and they
came back and like weren't I I guess weren't that scared of Blav.
Like one thing is if you're somebody who doesn't like Destiny,
that's true. You're not at risk of like that guy doxing you.
That's true. Um I don't think that gives anybody the right to
dox people who are against Destiny. I think that's pretty crazy.
Um,
but I think what happened was they became aware of some stuff
because Zoe had been shared some some texts from Destiny that
they felt like you were actually a worse person than they ever
realized and they wanted to say something about it and then you
were like, "Hey, can somebody repost their docs?"
So then I think they it was just like, "Oh, they really don't
like you now." So I don't know. That seemed to be what happened
to me that I So the one framing is they just came back and started
hating him out of nowhere. Another framing is, well, one of these
people might have had non-consensual things shared with them
and they didn't like that. They felt like they were somehow complicit.
They felt like a little guilty and gross and they felt like they
should say something. That's another way of framing it. You can
pick either interpretationally.
They were so afraid. They left the internet for 2 months and
then they came back and somehow made up with Blav and now they're
like my biggest anti fans. They they haven't left because of
me doxing people on that server, me threating. They're still
there. They're still chatting. They're not scared at all because
my community is not >> Oh, because they were already doxed.
Yeah. Uh there is there is something of like an effect. And listen,
maybe I if I wanted to ad hawk a criticism of me like right on
the fly, it might be something like, well, you know, Destiny
says he already doxed you. He's probably not going to try to
dox you more or something, so why don't you cool this cool this
off or or stop talking about him so that the community is not
at risk. I think that would be like a fair criticism if somebody
in my community said that to me. I'd be like, you know what,
that's I'm not going to, but I understand how you feel that way
and like protect yourself appropriately. You feel like you got
to go. I totally understand that. But once you're once you're
doxed, it's like, well, I don't know. I'm not What What else
are we supposed to do here? Like it's I'm in the pool. I didn't
want to get pushed in the pool. It's worse than that. Okay. It's
like a pool of acid. But now that I'm in the pool, it's like,
well,
yeah, you if I get out of the pool and you threaten to push me
again, I'm already wet. What What the [__] are you
even
>> Not very scary. We really don't engage in like very
much [__] up behavior >> Yeah, but I think
we >> says the guy who was posting doc spin links in his
chat three weeks ago. We we can acknowledge though that doxing
in general because the whole reason why they left the internet
because of blab >> oh and his community the the I guess
the comment on his community would be that they repost docs information
constantly.
Right. It wouldn't be that they are themselves seeking out and
and creating new docs like folios and posting them. it would
be that they repost the docses that Destiny posts all the time
>> or whatever is because they they are scared of consequences
of certain communities. Somebody's going to contact their work.
Somebody's going to farm doing it. Yes. Make up rumors about
>> Kiwi Farm's doing it. Yes. But not my >> So So
it seems pretty absurd that >> when they Oh, so we spiked
it up to 120.
that's pretty high. We never get that level of chatter. That's
where we spiked it up to was 120. Okay. Now, is that
uh maybe that's indicative of like
of something bad. I don't know.
I've always thought that kick has like a multiplier on it.
I don't know if you could explain it with a multiplier. Not totally
sure. Anyway, community. I don't know if we've ever done this
before. I don't know if that like I don't think anybody really
believes that when they say GG will do these things cuz it just
I don't think it's even happened before. >> Yeah. Yeah,
but the but the counter-argument is when you say that you would
kill uh Queman and Jtock and whoever else if you could, the the
argument is that effectively that that's stocastic rhetoric.
And that's where I don't want you to do first of all, I don't want
you to piss on my leg and tell me that.
>> Yeah, it's like stochastic rhetoric, but are they scared
of it? It's like what are you arguing? Yeah, I threaten to kill
these people, but like but are they scared? It's like, "No, no,
the the rhetoric itself is bad." That's what Conor's criticizing,
but they're not scared. Like, well, I don't negotiate with terrorists
right now. Like, I'm not going to negotiate with a terrorist,
a literal terrorist. That's how I feel about it. But that's like,
by the way, I know for a fact, and I've said this a hundred different
times, and I'll say it again,
the best thing for my like career as a streamer would be to move
on from this entirely. It would have been the best decision I
could have made as a streamer after like the first like three
days when these like leaks um when the Pixie lawsuit stuff came
out, the stuff about Cherry came out, when all this happened.
The best thing I could have done as a streamer is gone destiny.
But you know what else
is bad?
The Hassan is bad grift is so profitable. I could have still
been friends with Dan. Well, I mean, I still am best friends
with Dan actually. We talk every day, but I could still be friends
with Dan publicly. I could still go and like snark on Hassan
and nobody in Destiny's community would give me one ounce of
grief.
I could just ignore him. I could snark on Hassan. I could make
hundreds of thousands of dollars. I'm not kidding. I'm not joking.
That is 100% that would have been the easiest thing in the world
to do. I'm telling you, it doesn't get any easier. All the same
people who used to feed me all of the information on Hassan would
have kept feeding me
>> First of all, >> I don't want you to piss on my
leg and tell me that it's raining. >> But how many times
you you've watched my stream [laughter] years talking about stochastic
rhetoric? >> Yeah, but you've watched my stream for years.
Like how many times have I said right someone used to cancel
this guy blah blah blah. This is
>> boom hipster with the 500 kicks. That comes with a TTS
message if you add it next time.
500 kicks. That's a That's a TTS message right there that you
could have had in some very nice Indian voice. >> A private
call to um Willie Mac. I didn't even know this call was getting
published. Oh,
wait. Is Destiny saying here? And somebody see just check with
Willy Mack. Okay, I'm not even going to be not even going to
say anything bad about Willie Mack, but Destiny seems to be implying
that Destiny thought that entire conversation with Willy was
off the record.
Was that entire situation with Willy off the record? Did Willie
Max say it was all off the record and he published it or is Destiny
just lying here when he says that I thought that was off the
record?
So this is the this is the interview where he says he wants me
and Queen he talks about us violently, right? And Mr. Girl and
Lav as well. I think this is that one. Did Willie Mack say that
it was off the record and then actually just go and publish it?
Cuz I don't think Willy Mack would do that. Um Willie Mack's
a lot of things. I don't think he's just like a blatant liar
on Wait, no, he is a blatant liar. Can I How can I thread this
needle? He is like a blatant liar. So, I can't say that. That's
not true.
>> 10 live streamer fat gamer, former DGG awards winner
be Mr. Muton. >> Wow, what a twist at the end there. I
thought I was like, dude, I'm literally just trying to stream
here, man. What the? And then it is just twisted right around
at the end. That's crazy. Thank you very much for the 10 gummy
verse. Appreciate it, buddy. Okay.
All right. All right, we got the chat on screen.
>> Yeah, cool. >> But this is a call Mac. So, one,
I say this type of [__] all the time. I don't think
anybody takes it seriously. But number two, again, I can look
at the the response on the other side. Did they take it seriously?
No. None of them were deterred from covering my stuff. They all
covered it religiously. They all participated as much as they
could in all my court cases. When Justicle got outed by Pixie's
incompetence in in one of the public filings, he laughed about
it on stream. He didn't really seem like very concerned or scared
about it. Abby seems concerned. That's >> such a That's
such like a brain damaged talking point.
I didn't get concerned when the name JSTLK with an avatar was
in the chat was in the was in the filing. Guess what? People
already know that I've like talked to people about this. I literally
I literally talked about it on stream like like yeah I didn't
get concerned when the avatar was there. I laughed really hard
when the avatar was there because they did such a job of censoring
things. They censored the name and not the avatar and it's like
wait who is that? Who who is that guy? Right. It's a joke. It's
like a total joke on their part. It's really funny. But it didn't
matter because literally people know who I am. They know that
I was participating. That's not my privacy being violated,
right? Destiny's the one who's tried to violate my privacy.
But anyway, okay. It's that's a such a stupid talking point right
there. >> Scared. Although I think it's because she's burggering
herself and because he's asking her to. But um yeah, I just I
don't think that these people's complaints are very serious and
I don't think you should take them very seriously. I know they
try to represent them as serious, but like their behavior just
makes it very obvious that it's not serious at all. >> Okay.
But trying to evaluate the behavior from as objective as a perspective
as you can. Let let's ignore the way that they feel about it
for a
>> I know
because I was beat in the for
about stochastic rhetoric being so evil between 2019 and 2022.
They were effectively saying that Tucker Carlson is a stochcastic
terrorist because all of his rhetoric. So I know that the chances
of somebody acting on you saying like, "Oh, I'll keep Queen.
I'll keep J whatever." And also these people deserve to be doxed
or whatever. I think that DG or elements of DGG might dox. I
doubt anybody would ever like or IRL harass with the exception
of Darius. And like you said, Darius is not exactly an intimidating
figure. >> What? There is literally is somebody with a
criminal record for assault
and beyond that he's somebody who's been in multiple fights on
stream and beyond that he's a guy who's like in shape goes to
the gym he's pretty strong guy. What part of the like an intimidating
what part of sorry what part of the muscular
violent minority
isn't scary to you Connor Connor's a white nationalist remember.
Okay. What part of these things? This is literally He is like
literally your boogeyman.
This is your is like the violent minority who has multiple charges.
This is your Connor.
Well, sorry, not your but like what we think of as like that
would be like to you. It's like your worst thing in the world.
Legally white though. Not anymore. Actually, after he's been
charged a couple times, now they list him as black on everything.
Leafy Bell. So wrong. No longer legally white. After he got a
few assault charges, they started marking him down as black on
everything. Crazy how that
However, I think that the intent there is you stop covering me.
Stop talking [__] about me or else I'm going to dox
you or else um you know I'm going to use >> Yeah. Yeah.
Connor Connor gets it. This is I thought this was um there were
points here where I thought Connor did well because that is what's
happening, right? Destiny is saying if you talk about me I'm
going to dox you. That's what it is. Now, he's tried to contrive
an excuse for his audience to make it seem like it's okay. But
realistically, he just knows that that's always worked. So long
as he can paint whoever he's doing something bad to as worse
to his audience, they will acknowledge and they will allow anything.
They don't care. They'll allow literally anything.
They're good with anything, right? So, that's what he does. He's
got to come up with a reason that it's okay to dox these people
and they'll let him do whatever he wants. same community that
would defend and I probably can't necessarily cast the first
stone on this one but would defend the what the doc kid the not
doc kid the um dos kid defend him right >> castic rhetoric
to threaten you
>> I mean there's a lot of people who like cover me negatively
and and are critical of me like Ethan Klein is was a Nicholas
Dioro is a [__] >> yeah and then you blasted
his [__] like you didn't blast Nick Dior
Destiny didn't fight with Nick Dioro because he knew he wouldn't
win that fight. Destiny is very careful about picking his targets.
Probably why he mostly hangs out with smaller influencers. Can't,
you know, push them
Destiny literally only didn't fight with Nick because he literally
knows he would lose that fight, right? Nick's actually got an
audience. Nick's got a presence on Twitter. He didn't want to
he didn't want that smoke.
That was why he didn't pick that fight.
So, he knows as long as he doesn't have Nick working against
him actively, he can handle like everything else. But if he had
Nick working against him actively, like actively saying, "This
guy's out of his mind. He's on. He's crazy." That would work
against
>> [__] that you Wait, wait, wait. I What was
that voice crack? >> You blasted his like You didn't blast
Nick Dioro that you
>> [__] But wait, wait, wait. Well, I of course
I blasted Ethan's [__] because it's all on the internet.
But I didn't dox Ethan. I didn't dox Nicholas Dioro or I didn't
dox Willie Mack. Even though I think all these people acted
I Wait, did Queman dox Willy Mack? Why did he just say he didn't
dox Willy Mack?
Wasn't he also arguing that Queen while reviewing a retweet from
Destiny
was accused of doxing Willy? And Destiny goes, "I didn't dox
Willy Mack." That was like Queman. I didn't dox him.
>> There's a different That's That's the standard we're
working with, by the way. That's that's the standard we're working
with where Destiny can retweet that video doxing Willy Mack,
like getting some of his information out there. He can retweet
it explicitly and say, "You will Mac. I don't care that I did
it. I'll do it to anybody now." And Willy Mack's like, "Yes,
Destiny, sir. Yes, Destiny. Yes, Massa. Yes, Massa Destiny. Yes.
Yes. That's cool. That's so awesome, Massa Destiny." And then
Queman's like, "Oh, I didn't mean to do that." And he deletes
it all. Gets his clipper to take it down. Censors everything
for his bod. And everybody's like, "Quean's the evil person here.
This evil Jew doxed
Israel's strongest soldier,
his partner." Okay, it's it's crazy that that's the standard
we're working with between their behavior and Jessica hosting
a server where people are dedicating an inordinate amount of
time obsessively talking about me, stalking me, harassing me,
emailing people. >> Actually, we made a channel. I don't
even know if we could check this. What's the number of messages
in e- rape defense squad since it started? and then general chat
because general chat we do filter out the Destiny stuff there.
I mean you could post a link or something in general chat but
if it's starting to get into like an actual conversation it gets
redirected to rape defense squad. So I think that cut down talk
on Destiny like really significantly was moving that all over
into the rape defense squad channel. People around me like it's
a different type of behavior and then showing up in other communities
to do it like the that's the biggest thing. The reason why and
it's it's so sad that like Kiwi Farms >> well after Yeah.
after Destiny, you know, explicitly platformed to talk [__]
about me multiple times, right? And tried to build up a community
around a tal about me, after he did that and then he kept talking
about me, I was like, "Oh, I should go around and like tell my
side of the story now. I should like go and and actually be willing
to talk to people, listen to them, tell my side of the story."
He's like, "Well,
what? You can't do that." For the most part, they follow this,
but my thread is just crazy unhinged. There's this concept of
like, "Don't touch the poop. If you want to make a community
and you want to gossip about somebody, I think you should have
the right to do that. You want to say horrible evil things. You
want to make fun of the way they look, the way they talk, the
way they act, whatever. I think fine. I mean, it's America. Well,
if you're in America, it's America. Whatever. Freedom of speech,
that's fine. But when it starts to leak over and infect every
single community when I'm talking to Pisco and Dubbie is donating
$1,000 during our talk to try to get his points across.
Why did Doobie do that? We all know why Doobie did that, right?
We all know what Destiny threatened and tried to menace Doobie
with his docks, right? He tried to say that he would dox Doobie
and Doobie went Doobie went hold on hold on
>> he went
I spit on you terrorist
I throw money at you to [__] on you now
you terrorist that's what Doobie did but Destiny caused that
all on his own is the source of all of his own problems right
Dubie was not going around doing crazy [__] like
that and I will say spending $1,000 to donate just messages talking
Destiny I do think That's crazy. Okay, I will I will say not
that it's crazy as in like it's unhinged and it's evil, but it's
just like I would never spend $1,000 to Destiny. Okay, I thought
that was but crazy in like an awesome way. All right,
but Doobie would never have done that if if Destiny hadn't threatened
him explicitly. Um, we were all enjoying Pisco debating Hutch
and Litterbox and Destiny made it about him. Well, hold on. But
he has to wait. That wasn't the right chat. We're all enjoying
Pisco debating Hutch and Litterbox and Destiny made it about
him. Uh yeah, I mean twice really, right? Like there was a whole
debate going on with the communism thing. Destiny made that about
him and then there was a whole thing going on about Ethan Klein
and Destiny made it about him again. Now hard for me to cast
the first stone in that cuz I do think that was about me to some
extent, right? There is a undeniable overlap in the narrative
Destiny tries to present of how
like you can do this this sort of like um tertiary attachment
to other communities and then punish people as if they're the
primary offenders from those other communities and tying like
Olivart to denims. It's like the same process, right? That's
the same chemical process going on to distill something down
into like uh anything against this person is justified. And so
I do believe there's a basis that they have to they have to defend
with the Ethan stuff where they have to step in and go like,
"Whoa, are you like defending like the JTO community? Are you
defending like the snarkers? Are you why are you defending
And it's like, "No, I I just think that and Connor seems to have
keyed into it as well, where it's the it's the what is it the
dignity culture thing, right? Where it's like you you have the
right to not just be killed in retribution for something you
didn't do." That's like a general concept we have in liberal
democracies. You have the right to not be killed in retribution
for something like your brother did or even like your friend
did or like in the case of the Kiwi Farms thing like somebody
from your university did. Yeah, there's undercurrens in Israel,
Gaza as well. I think it's it's like a little more understandable
the worse the conduct gets. But by the way,
also
nobody really states I don't think I've ever stated maybe I have
with Destiny. I don't know. I maybe shouldn't say this with Destiny,
but with Ethan Klein, I always say I understand how Ethan gets
into that mind space, right? I understand how he gets into that
head space and how he's upset. He's frustrated. That makes total
sense to
It's a It's on the people around him to step in and go, "No,
Ethan. Ethan, too far. Too far, Ethan." Right? If you don't have
people around you when you're going crazy who will step in and
say, "Hey, man. You need to chill now. You need to chill." Okay?
If you
um you ever tried contacting YouTube or Discord with clear evidence
of Destiny doxing people, including you? I think they may deplatform
them even if it's not on their platform. Um possibly.
I'm going to say I have not done that yet.
I haven't done that yet. I've
there's a reason I know like that whole timeline and stuff. Okay.
[snorts] I think it's just gotten to the point where I do have
to do something like uh this guy is explicitly trying to my community
by threatening to dox anybody in it, right? Which like I I guess
if you thought if you went with the Trump hypothetical where
it's like he really did think the election was stolen. If you
wanted to give him that, it's like well now I probably just have
to like actually do something to defend myself. Like you can't
just let this person do whatever they want because they're delusional.
Anyway,
where was I here? Oh, counterpoints hit on the right thing with
the dignity culture thing. the right to not be, you know, the
victim of retributive
violence, obviously. And then I forget where I went after that.
>> And I'm talking to Doobie on Wickstream and justicles
and his >> Oh, server saying um Doobie shouldn't be using
talking points unless I'm giving them to him. And then >> I
did say that. I did say that. The only thing I think Dubbie took
from me was the um I was I was telling Dubbie like, "Don't bring
that up. Bring this up." But he didn't listen to me. Doobie wasn't
listening. That was the whole point of the comment. I'm like,
"Doobie should only say the things I tell him to say. Don't bring
up LAUREN DE LAGUNA. DUBY, NO DUBY, DON'T BRING UP NO, DUBY,
don't bring up Lauren de Laguna. So, I did try to say like, "Hey,
don't bring that up." That's like a really silly thing to bring
up. But unfortunately, Dubie was just cooking on his own supply
Unfortunately,
like that's probably for the best. But yeah, I would never I
would never have brought up the Lauren De Laguna thing. I would
have just hammered the Darius thing. and Win Justistical and
all of the anti fans are in Pisco server and they're just rereaming
like random DMs of my like that's it's a >> I think he
was talking about how somebody was arguing with me in the Pisco
server about the oh no hold on that's actually wrong that was
in Wick server and that was because people were like no no was
I was sitting there and Doobie was arguing with people and I
just streamed the DMs like the Willy DMs I just pulled up the
Willy tweet right Willy Mac show
I just I literally had this sitting on
it was the last one here.
I said this DM, this set of DMs was just sitting on my screen
like this. He's like, when they're sitting in Discord streaming
my DMs. It's like, well, we're having an argument. I was streaming
the evidence. Basically, people are like, "Hey,
what is rereaming DMs?" Well, this is rereaming. I just had the
tweet of Willie Max thing up cuz we were having an argument about
it. Somebody was arguing that like you don't know that he has
on his computer and it's like no it's inarguable from this that
he had on his computer.
No, no, no. I didn't stream this in Pisco's Discord. I did not
stream this in Pisco's Discord. This was in Wick's Discord. I
was there.
Uh Doobie was there. The Zetsui guy was there who I used to know
from the Destiny community. There were a couple other people
as well. This is Yeah. Crazy that JTO is rereaming Destiny's
DMs. I just had this up and I think he like hopped in and he
like looked at this. He's like, "What are you I was like, "Oh,
we're just discussing like whether or not you had seam." That
was that was how that conversation went.
Very funny.
do you understand that's like a different thing than just cuz
you just said with people who are criticizing you, right? You
understand it's like a different thing in kind, right?
Wait, I also did that after
after like after him doxing people like him. Dude, I didn't go
and do that. I was like I try to deescalate by just not bringing
this [__] up. I actually do. He's the one who posted
like I posted a bunch of doc bids of people around me and I'm
like, "Dude, what are you what are you doing?" So, yeah. Then
I started like talking to people. I'm like, "Yeah, he really
is a bad guy. He really did have here." Yes, there is no other
way to interpret this. Yeah. Anyway.
>> Yeah. I I think the >> You don't see it sounds
like you don't think it is cuz you were like, "Yeah,
Dude, dude, Connor, Connor's like trying to not question Destiny.
And Destiny's like, "Um, you're you're hedge there. That's unacceptable."
Connor, that's totally unacceptable. Connor, >> Chatty
Nickel, thank you for the gifted
>> You didn't agree with me enough, Connor. You don't agree
with me. Hard enough
>> Excuse me, Connor. >> Well, I was going to articulate
the difference. I I think the the difference
we're
public figures or semi-public figures and so any of our behavior
that is made available to the public you can criticize whereas
I think that what differentiates uh Kiwi Farms doc bin whatever
is that in my opinion that they play cute with doxing information
they play cute with like swatting and all that kind of stuff
where they're like oh well you know it's against our terms of
service to swat it's against our terms of service to touch the
poo. But of course, like the purpose of doxing is to get somebody
else to touch the poo, >> Sure. Well, to be clear, I don't
know what you heard this and I don't know if I'm just not aware
of this. Doc spin is to my understanding, docin is like paypin
but for doces. I I don't know where this idea that like doc spin
is this crazy community. It's just a place where people post
docses. I don't like I say on stream, but like you can >> Well,
right. But the the purpose, right?
>> So, that's fairly crazy because I don't know if you
guys know this, Destiny wrote this whole thing. Okay. Keffles
a case study on internet terrorism and mass media manipulation.
If you're unaware of this, all right, if you're unaware of this
in this, some people are aware of it. I see many chatters are
aware of it. Desi referenced a website that he called website
zero.
So this is in the context of Kiwi Farms was getting all of the
blame,
right? All of the blame for
all of the harassment that was going to Keles. And Destiny made
an argument that like, hey, Keeles doesn't care about where the
harassment is coming from. She just wants to take down Kiwi Farms.
Sound familiar? Like you you actually don't know where something's
coming from. You're just attributing it to someone cuz you want
to see them destroyed. Sound like familiar? Almost like he might
have taken a tactic. So he talked about this place. There's another
website we're going to be discussing extensively in this section.
I don't want to give more spotlight to a potentially harmful
website that hosts personal information. So I'll be referring
to it as website zero. While it's true that Kiwi Farms has hosted
her doces, is there any evidence that any of the swattings came
from Kiwi Farms or that it was even Kiwi Farms who originally
produced those doces? Careful reading of her thread would show
that Kiwi Farms users don't find out about Serenti's raid until
she's actually announced it on her GoFundMe. It's possible that
one could think Kiwi Farms users would attempt to swat her secretly.
But does it really make sense when it's being claimed that users
on the site are publicly threatening Serenti? It seems reasonable
that we would need a high bar of proof that serious harassment
like swatting is actually originating from a website before attempting
to wipe it from the internet. Wow. It's almost like he understood
these concepts perfectly when it served him.
Like totally totally perfectly.
So I would wonder why Destiny either did Destiny lie back here
and not was he lying about Docin back here or is he lying now?
This is this is Destiny's article on Keffles by the way.
Just another little aside here, a case study on internet terrorism
and mass media manipulation. Internet terrorism. Internet terrorist.
Kind of like e- rapist. Electronic, right? Sort of the same concept.
A a clearly digital modifier on top of like a a very hyperbolic
word. E- rapist. Internet
Uh e- rapist. Very very bad. And okay, you can't use that word.
Internet terrorist. Very awesome. Very cool. Very very edgy and
funny to use. Wow.
>> Is to make it easily accessible. So if you want to digitally
harass somebody, then you can easily >> Yeah, sure. It's
definitely a threatening or an intimidation thing for sure. But
there's also kind of a catch22 here as well in that like if you
dox a rando like nothing's probably happening as person. Nobody
gives a about them, right? Like nobody's >> Well, I mean
I I would say that's why I'm relatively chill. My my public information
is probably relatively
>> weaponized ignorance is so OP. Dustin, I can't tell
what you're saying in the chat here.
Are you saying that we're weaponizing ignorance? Destiny's weaponizing
ignorance. I literally can't tell. I I I don't know.
Um I think it's Destiny, but I'm just not sure. >> Fine.
But the reason why I'm not too
>> freaked out about
Hold on. Let me back it up two seconds here. >> I would
say that's why I'm >> relatively chill. My My public information
is probably relatively easy to find, but the reason why I'm not
freaked out about it is because it's like, okay, you know my
address. >> Yeah. Well, if you come if you come to my address,
like I've already talked to local law enforcement and I've already
told them, you know, that I'm a public figure and I could get
swatted. Um, they allegedly took notes down and all that kind
of stuff. Uh, but besides that, if you come to my address, like
we, you know, we might have problems depending on what your intent
is.
>> Is he worse now or was I actually just way more mind
raped than I thought two years ago? I would assume there's a
couple things going on here. It's um
dude literally people in Connor's chat in Destiny's chat are
saying why does that even matter Connor? Uh very interesting
very funny. Is he worse now? Oh yeah so this comment from Tommy.
Okay so with Destiny I do think he's a little worse now but there
is also like the information thing where like when you only get
information in that context in that community you start to develop
very skewed ideas of like what's going on right? Um and I I do
think there's something to be said there. Now, it's entirely
possible that people in my community get skewed ideas of what's
going on, too. Right?
I just think that if you look at the record, if you look at the
facts, I'm pretty confident I
right? And that I can clearly point to the things where Destiny
is lying. And when Destiny wants to attack me, it's not really
my conduct where he points out me lying about something. He points
out things where it's like, "Oh, people adjacent to this guy
said this or somebody I'm like webbing to him said this or did
this." Right? The closest thing he's got to explain his doxing
campaign is the cyber thing that again occurred I believe eight
months or so became public eight months or so after his doxing
campaign started. Some creature talking about you. Wait, what
is this? I'm totally fine doing a BMI check against Stardust.
I I know I BMI mog this person like 100%.
I don't know why the actual hog is is speaking right now.
Get back in the pen, hog. Get back in the pen.
Okay. I I don't know why she's speaking. Why is she watching
me? Don't watch then off. Nobody asked you to watch. Pull up
the clip. I'm good.
I'm good. It's [__] up how well you did that. Uh
it's kind of like the pterodactyl sound I make when I'm laughing.
Like I'll do the laugh. That's like the inhaling laugh. The shrill.
It's kind of like that. So,
>> but the >> we continue. >> Um
Okay. So, so I guess the >> but this but this I don't I
don't buy this like you're a public figure so you have to accept
infinite levels of obsessive harassment that bleeds over into
every single other community that you're a part of
that I don't think I have to accept that and if we're going to
play that game then I then I will like I don't think doxing is
illegal I don't think I would try to break the law but like I'm
going to go up to and including anything that is like within
the legal confines of >> well I don't I don't know about
accepting but just as an example like the and maybe this would
make the content less boring like obvious or it would make it
more boring. Um so so maybe I'm I'm advocating for more boring
content which is not good but effectively like no nobody's going
to harass me because of my 40k.
I I don't think that
has he said that what uh has he said what harassment he's received
that isn't us talking about him in our own server.
I don't Well, he's try he's going to say that it's the Kiwi Farms
harassment that he gets and then they do the argument where they
dance around and they try to say, "Well, um the examples I got
recently from DJers were I think what was it?" It's like, um
oh, I believe the the best example somebody had recently was,
"Well, you guys asked how old was Rose and that's like a dog
whistle at a doxing campaign that's taking place on Kiwi Farms."
It's
no, that's like literally the first issue that popped up was
people were asking how old this person was because the solo person
explicitly publicly said she was a minor and tons of people were
talking about it. Believe they said it in multiple places, talked
about it in like Discords and Yeah.
>> Uh, you know, name it. I don't think Adam Mockler gets
like, maybe I'm wrong, I don't think he gets like doxed, harassed,
people in his
stuff. >> He does not.
Well, in that's what I would say. It's because he shows up. He
does his job. He >> I understand this, but to repeat this,
I don't Well, maybe not repeating it to you, but I've said this
a million times. The biggest annoying thing about this court
case was the court case had to do with a conversation I had in
2022 about a video that I made in 2020 that was leaked on the
internet then in 2024.
So, like >> the all of the annoying like harassment and
stalking and >> wait a video he leaked in.
So, like the all of the relationship,
but I've said this a million times. The biggest annoying thing
about this court case was the court case had to do with a conversation
I had in 2022 about a video that I made in 2020 that was leaked.
>> Okay, but the like nobody's the conduct was in 2022.
Why would it be about who cares if it's about a video you made
in
That's such a weird That's such a weird way of framing that to
include that part about a video I made in 2020.
Yeah, I think it didn't matter when you made the video. What
>> leaked on the internet then in 2024.
So like >> the all of the annoying like harassment and
stalking and obsession over like my personal life and stuff is
is stuff that it was all in the past for me. Like it's not really
anything that is currently like I I just don't do relationship
stuff, drama stuff, interpersonal stuff on stream, which has
just hasn't been part of my stream for like two years
Yeah, that's uh all of your court stuff would be this. All literally
every update you do in your court case is that why is he how
is Connor supposed to just sit here and like accept these obvious
and blatant lies and reframings? Is he supposed to just sit here
and nod like he believes anything Destiny is saying right now?
Like it's obviously not true.
And he also goes on food shop stream. No food shops. He's also
he also goes on food shop stream to explicitly talk about his
court case and talk about drama in his personal life. He had
a whole conversation with Lav like what three months ago 6 months
ago? I can't I can't remember exactly how long. Around 3 to 6
months ago he had a whole conversation with Lab on food shops
stream. I think it's just jarring how he is now. Well, no. Connor
does know Connor is trying not to Connor doesn't want to come
on the stream. Connor is trying to walk the line between making
his friend look bad and holding him to account in some way that's
meaningful. That is what Connor is trying to do. Okay, I'll give
Connor like the charity and not just say it's about money. He
wants to hold his friend a little bit accountable, but not make
him look like a complete.
Okay, but Destiny is lying so starkly and so obviously
that it's like almost like it it
it just baffles the mind.
It's like really really difficult. He wants to say he brought
up all the things when he gets pressed on it by others. Well,
I don't know if he's bringing up all the things. He should bring
up the Supreme thing in my opinion. That's my opinion at least.
I think um Destiny recently has started he he leaked some DMs
that he had litigating like some
he didn't leak them publicly yet. And at the risk of like drawing
attention to it, I think maybe just I'll read Supreme's one message
here. Okay. I didn't know too much about this, but I saw I caught
up on this in one of the chats here just a little while ago.
Where is it? Here.
Um
I'm going to read just this one message. Give me a second. Oh,
hold on. Oh, maybe I won't find this. Maybe this isn't here.
Oh, maybe. One second. I'll take one more look and see. So, somebody
came into my Discord this morning threatening to leak some DMs
that basically only have been shared, I think, between Pixie,
Destiny, and Supreme. So, Supreme and Pixie dated and then
there was some weird. Okay. And Destiny appears to have leaked
this to some random just like a random account joined my Discord
was like saying that they saw these DMs and Supreme's like evil.
And Supreme said this was his response was there was some drama
between Pixie and I when we stopped dating, but none of those
claims are true. Steven is trying to seed this narrative because
it requires going through our messages to disprove it, which
is inherently uncomfortable and embarrassing for both her and
I. He now he has some of these messages because I suggested she
uh I suggested to her to take the issue to him to help resolve
it and we trusted him. Now, why would I do that if I didn't stand
behind my conduct? And beyond that, Pixie and I have no issues
and none of this is anyone's business. The only reason it's coming
up is because Steven wants to punish us. And he thinks dangling
our personal lives in front of the public is enough to silence
either of us. But he should know by now that it won't. Especially
since getting what he wants would only prove that everything
he said about me is a lie.
So basically Destiny's trying to like drop to somebody. I have
no idea who like some idea of like what happened with Pixie and
Supreme.
And somebody came in and was like basically talking about these
DMs. I assumed what I told Supreme initially was I I think this
person's literally just trying to get like comments on the record
so somebody can cover it on stream. They're basically trying
to get you to go that didn't happen so that Destiny can go, "Oh,
you say that didn't happen?" Well, he's trying to do like the
Candace thing, right? So, I just It's pretty predictable what
he's doing and why he's doing it. He's like a bad person,
but
yeah, it is what it is.
It is what it is. So, I think counterpoint should ask him not
about that necessarily, but it's just about the Supreme doxing
and stuff. Supreme's kept it very tame. Supreme's never been
unhinged
>> aside from whatever gets like drug up in the court case.
>> Okay. Well, I I pressed I pressed you this uh pressed
you about this though in the past though. Are you still engaging
casually with women who uh you may or may not know a lot about
them >> and therefore they could blow up on you? >> I
mean, the biggest change in my behavior is I just don't mess
with any like streamer YouTuber people anymore if they're an
online person. I just that's like the number one red flag I found
more than And Connor just has to sit there again.
when Destiny just like openly lies to his face. He just has to
sit there again
and go, "Okay, Destiny.
Like literally Connor's going to bring up the fact that he feels
humiliated. He either has or he brought it up already. I can't
remember. But um he's going to bring up the feel the idea that
he gets humiliated when these when these things go badly because
he's saying Destiny is somebody you should trust, somebody you
should be confident in. No way Connor doesn't bring up empath.
Uh, I don't believe he does by name, but that would be the one
that we're all talking about in this case. There's also him going
to hang out with Lauren Southern in Austin, Texas or whatever,
hang out with her. Like, he does still with he does still [__]
with these people. And then he'll just say, "Well, there was
nothing going on." It's like, "This person literally stayed in
your apartment." This is like a random from online you just let
stay in your apartment for what reason? But >> Whatever.
D more than
criminal record more than anything else is if a person is a streamer
or like any kind of public social media figure then that's always
like the biggest red flag and that's been the number one thing
that's kept more or less everything off of my stream for the
past like two
>> Again has not been off of his stream for the past two
years. This is just a lie >> But you're you're negative
followers like me and probably Kyla to a degree. >> Sure.
Uh there are people where you
if you engage with them casually, you do not spend enough time
getting to know them. Therefore, you don't know who they are.
Therefore, if the relationship sour, they could very quickly
become an online person in order to blow your [__]
>> Yeah. Yeah, I mean I guess it I mean I guess it I mean
I guess theoretically that could happen. Hug [laughter] generally
speaking generally speaking I would say over the past two years
this is like significantly decreased. My guess is by the end
of >> Oh well it's not it's not that it doesn't happen
anymore. It's significantly decreased now. >> This year
it'll basically be at zero. Um but yeah
>> guys I finally got rid of all the toxic people in my
life in 2025.
I've never I've never heard this before. He's just saying it
in a different way. Guys, I'm I've gotten in 2025. I got rid
of all the toxic people in my life. >> Um yeah, I mean
like all I just want to share this and then >> I should
have see I should have prepped for this cuz then we could have
done bingo and we didn't get to do bingo now and it would have
been really funny. >> Honestly, I'll stop moral talking
unless people are finding it entertaining. the the
I think the reason why as one of
internet friends uh I want it to be zero is because like
>> the
you've paid a lot of of people around you well number one you've
paid a lot of consequences for
>> don't bring up EC don't bring up EC so in a week literally
nobody not even the cult believes it literally the cult can't
even believe this even the cult is like okay Oh, don't on my
leg and tell me it's rain, okay? You doing here, don't
seriously man >> for the things that have happened. Uh,
number two, the people around you who want what's in your best
interest or whatever, if they go out on a relational limb, and
I do think it's funny that effectively like you've known Dan
forever, which is why Dan is, you know, your friend. Uh, Kyla
and I, I would say, are more conservative in some regards. And
I think that loyalty is probably something that we value. Uh
which is why I think that despite some turbulent times um we
haven't just totally been like oh Stephen let's backstab him
instantaneously.
Um so but but the point with that is the reason why I wanted
to drop the zero is because
I feel like Connor is saying this cuz he's watched at least one
of my streams where I say I don't even like watching Destiny
anymore. This guy's boring. I just watch I just watch Kyla and
Connor and watch them try to cope with all of the bad decisions
Destiny makes. all of the things that happened to the people
around him and I just watch them pull the broom out and have
to sweep for whatever the new outrage is. That's what's way funnier
to me is like I'm just watching for when these people will break
and realize that this guy is incapable of changing. I'm just
I'm enjoying that that process for me that's like the funniest
thing in the world. I do watch Destiny when he lies about me,
but like realistically it's just hey that impath chant thing
this guy just called Darius a hard R with Aerodite right there.
Yeah, I think that's funny. I think it's funny to watch people
react to that and talk about it. Very funny when the Rose When
the Rose stuff comes out through those transcripts, that's very
funny. Okay, watching them sweep, it's very goofy, very funny.
>> Cuz I I don't care if you goon. I don't care if you
have fun. I don't care if you're promiscuous. Whatever. You're
an adult. You need to make up your own decisions. But when you're
loose and fast with random people and you trust them too much
too quickly, what what ends up happening is if they decide if
they decide to blow your [__] up and they're private
people, but they decide to be internet people and then blow your
up, we look like fools. Uh Kyla and I look like fools because,
you know, we're we're trying to be your friend. We want to be
your friend, etc., etc. But then it looks like you're not learning
lessons from repeated social blowups.
>> Yeah, I guess. Sure.
Yeah, I guess I I think I could understand how that I got understand
that. I don't even remember what the response to this is.
>> I wish I know it's really hard and I know that you guys
are in compromised. >> Sure. I know you guys are in compromised
positions, I guess, as a result of that. I I guess it's impossible.
I do wish it was possible for some people to say like, "Oh, like
sometimes a person makes a mistake and it doesn't have to reflect
negatively on me." uh like or you um but >> dude it's the
willful like just one mistake just one mistake guys
I'd say it's probably more the like
it's particularly insulting when you get somebody who spits on
black people in the street calling them the hard R has videos
that you're aware of on the internet of her doing that and then
you're like this is my friend who I can trust and leave in my
apartment for long periods of time
um that
speaks to your character it speaks to Connor's character when
he defends you and you say that that's a mistake. It doesn't
seem like a mistake. It seems like a very calculated decision.
I don't think this is some impulsive decision to let Impath Chance
take your place for months on end or sorry, sorry, like a week
week, couple weeks, I forget exactly. I don't think there was
like an impulsive decision he made,
right? And I'm not even getting into the obviously like morally
bad behavior. the obvious like extremely bad behavior of recording
people without their consent, of sending people's tapes you shot
with them without their consent. Right? I haven't gotten of doxing
people. I haven't even gotten into the actual like bad behavior
here. I'm just talking about this is one thing where Connor is
trying to say like, "Hey, maybe you shouldn't." He's basically
hinting at the impath chance thing without saying it, right?
Like that's what he's doing here
after Destiny just lies to him and says multiple times in this
conversation, "My personal life doesn't appear on like any of
my doesn't appear in my content, not on stream at all. It's uh
it's crazy." Uh Chris, if you want to see that, you would probably
want to go check Rumble, their Rumble page. >> Apparently,
this is impossible, I guess, in this day and age, but um yeah.
Well, in bird birds of a feather flock together, so effectively
>> like I again,
okay, this is the only thing I'm ever going to say. This is
so because I don't really like uh I'm not super engaged with
the KF thread,
but I just I have to make like one pseudo joke. It's not even
really a joke. It's like actually just reality. Okay,
if I wanted to know if Empath Chan and Destiny were friends or
I would bet all of my money, if I had to pick
one of two perspectives, I have to ask this question and I have
to pick who's correct. Okay, let's say we do a thousand simulations.
Two different people are saying whether or not I empathize Destiny.
One of the people is Destiny and the other people, sorry, the
other person is Blav.
I'm betting on Blav every single time to tell me whether or not
that's happening. This guy is just a proven and he doesn't have
to tell the truth. Okay? He doesn't have to.
But this guy's just a proven liar every single time. I'm sorry
that you have to lie all of the time about all of your personal
interactions and totally reshape them and renarrativize them.
Like set a narrative on all of them all the time, but you are
like the least trustworthy person on any of your personal experiences.
And it sucks to say because I don't think what Blab's done in
terms of the doxing in terms of even uh kind of like like a logging
Destiny is good.
But I will say that like he has created a very compelling point
that Destiny just lies about everything all the time.
Again, he's not I I don't think Destiny has to tell the truth
about his life, right? But the thing is is he lies constantly
and he lies in ways that defend him. When he got confronted by
Mr. girl about his bad behavior with Anavoir. His response was,
"I'm cleaner than anybody in the game. I'm way cleaner that you
could look at all my DMs. If my DMs ever get leaked, I'm going
to be the person who's never done a thing wrong. I've never done
anything wrong."
This was, I believe, within months of sending the Pixie Tape.
Okay? Like, there is just factual, compelling evidence that this
guy lies constantly to make him seem like a better person. It's
unfortunate that it's just the case. It's just true. like, you
know, regardless of whether or not guilt by association is a
correct perspective to
>> uh, you only have to ask why would you meet a person
like Impath Chan for other reasons than what are her positive
character traits for a person like Destiny? Well, it seems like
he's letting a lot of things go just for loyalty. Maybe Impath
Chan is loyal. Okay, maybe I don't realize it. Empath Chan's
loyal. Seems like he's totally totally in the rearview mirror
so long as you're loyal and being a racist also in the rearview
mirror.
No, none of this is a problem. We're good with all of this. By
the way, that clip, that clip's going to sink me with the cultists.
Okay, but it turns out when I was like, "Oh, I totally disavow
all of these things. I'll never joke about this stuff." When
I was doing that, I also was getting over by the cultists. So,
realistically, probably just got to stop worrying about that
demographic of people. >> It's one that people use all
the time. >> I guess on our side they do. Yeah,
Oh, this is an interesting point that a mark of loyalty would
be attacking a certain person. I didn't even think about this.
That is something that both
Chops and Impath Chen share.
>> Listen, you know what? I'm just going to become a conservative
and then we're Gucci. Okay. You and me can go conservative together
and then I can >> All right. Yeah, we could be. >> So,
they don't care on that side. So, >> they don't care about
anything.
>> They don't care. Good job.
>> So, and >> they don't care about anything.
Isn't Connor a conservative?
Wait, Destiny is dating the end girl on Twitter? No, but he did
hang out with her multiple times. Let her stay in his apartment
for weeks while he was gone. At least one full week while he
was not there. She was staying at his apartment. She was just
Was she not just recently back in Miami? Why did I Why did I
think she was back in Miami for some kind of content recently?
Am I crazy? Was she not just back there? She's taking many photos
of his bed. Very weird. Oh, fresh and fit. Yeah.
So, I do wonder what she was doing on Fresh and Fit. I wonder
who she was hanging out with for Christmas. Do wonder what was
going on there. Oh, that would be really if they uh they spent
Christmas together. I don't know who he was spending Christmas
with, but I'm just saying hypothetically she was there in Miami.
Maybe she posted pictures I don't follow, so I have no idea.
Maybe she post pictures somewhere else. That would be really
weird. Anyway, we continue.
Anyways, that that was realistically just for the sake of momentum.
If you had something else that you wanted to talk about, I'd
be happy to talk about it. We we know who he wasn't spending
time with. Shut up. Shut up. None of you are funny. Like eight
of you said that at the same time. Shut up. And also we're going
to try to stick away from that even though
even though it's difficult. Probably try to stay steer. >> But
I did uh want to kind of ask you about the Epstein thing. See
if you'd evolved on that at all. And then I did want to talk
about the moral systems because I do think people are perceiving
it differently. Um but that's what I had. That's all I had. >> Okay.
Yeah. Well, how's that going for you in general otherwise? >> And
that is where we stop our coverage. Not interested. Um, I talked
to Connor a little bit. I'm trying to be less harsh on Connor.
Okay. Trying to be
less harsh on Connor. As best we can. Okay. As best we can.
Where are we going now? There's like a whole bunch of this stuff
to cover. There's like there was this and then there's him covering
the mutant clip and then what else was there? There's something
from his stream
him responding to Pisco and stuff. I don't remember the order
any of this went in. Just get it all out. Yeah. Well, I'm going
to, but I'm saying like, can we can I get can I get this
Sorry, I forget the order that this all went in. I unfortunately
I think I I told you guys I think I spent a lot of time on my
phone over Christmas because I didn't take most of my devices
with me. I didn't take my streaming computer. I had my laptop
there, but I it's like right now,
so I was mostly on my phone, but I didn't get a chance of I wasn't
following content at all. It's like having rando conversations
in Discord. Where's my
There we go. This is funny.
Is it funny? What is this? We're going to go on to something
else here. It's going to be the rest of this stuff.
Well, who's going to win? It's going to be Gavin Newsome against
JD Vance because JD Vance is subhuman and Gavin Newsome hugs.
>> Is JD Vance is subhuman?
>> What? What makes you say that? >> Uh he's got
a very short total facial width to height ratio. >> Oh,
let's go. The looks m the looks max rating on JD Vance. I can't
wait. Give me a second. I need to fix this audio real quick.
Uh Ry, what's the next thing in timeline order? If you if you
know I know you sent me a clip or something. I'm I'm trying to
figure this out but also fix this audio.
Okay, I'm back. >> He's obese. Uh very recessed side profile
whereas Newsome is like 63 Chad. >> So you're JD is very
tall. JD is got to >> Well, still
Gavin Newsome obviously mogs him to >> So you a Newsome
head. You prefer Newsome to the vice president. >> I'm
just telling you who's going to win. Do you prefer him though?
honestly,
[sighs and gasps] it's it's hard to say, but Newsome being that
much more of a moger and like having a president who's like fat
and especially that young, >> you think he's I don't think
he's fit. >> I would say >> he's a bigger guy for
sure. >> Just like
>> I I could see I didn't think of JD Vance as fat. I thought
he had like chubby cheeks, but then I saw the picture of him
in the Marines and I was like, "Oh, JD is kind of I thought I
thought he just had like chubby cheeks, right?"
But he's got like the big he's got like if you ever see look
at the picture of JD Vance in the Marines, he kind of looks like
Clvicular. If you look at him in his like Marines picture, oh,
not this one. This one. Okay, maybe not like clvicular, but like
he Okay, really? Right. Like he doesn't just have he's not always
going to have a fat face. I will say though, when he's like gets
to 40, it's probably for him. He already he does have like a
wider face already. JD's low 30. I don't think JD Vance is low
30% body fat. 30 You start to get like round at 30%.
You get like the You start to become a like proto Chris Christie
at 30% or 35%. I think JD is like 25.
I think
I think JD's like 25.
You think 35?
35 massive. No, I don't think I reacted to this already. I think
I held off talking about the moot stuff. I'm pretty sure. Oh.
Oh, no. This one. No, I did talk about this one. There is this
one. I want the clip of him talking about the mutin thing, though.
If that's here. I saw the clip of it somewhere. I assume it's
from Substance, but I'm not totally
Is it the Is it the There's this one
There's this one. There's
not this one. I wanted to see what that was. Oh, I I could have
sworn there's a clip of it somewhere. Is there really no clip?
I'm good. I'm not really caring about No, it's somewhere. It's
like maybe it's in my Discord. Hold on. I'm trying to think of
what he said. Oh,
hold on. It might be in my Discord. I'll I'll see if I can find
this uh clip really quickly. We'll run this one real >> I
gave the ducks information of Rose to Kiwi Farms. >> This
is the one.
Dude, I was I was saying he gave like the PII to Kiwi Farms and
then said you should >> I'm just curious for the few people
that actually keep up with that thread. Does anybody have a link
to the post where Blav was posting pictures where he was going
street by street through the entire city of whatever the she
was in trying to find where she lived based on her. I actually
don't know this and he knows so kudos to him. I don't know. Was
Blav in the right city?
Did they know the city? I thought it was like they didn't know
the city, but maybe I'm wrong on that. I could be I could easily
be wrong on that. Um
I think car and like the background and some maybe have like
it's so funny like I can't believe
like all of you guys were obsessively trying who's somebody.
So I feel like when I say this all of you guys I didn't know
where she was. The only post I ever made about this was saying
you tried to dox this person cuz you're psychotic. You guys think
I'm exaggerating cuz you either somebody find it. Somebody somebody
here must have it. So I'm I'll just read cuz this guy's got pictures
of this rose girl posted everywhere, too, which is a little bit
weird. And I guess this would all be child on Blab's computer
by the way. But so this is a post by Blive in June probably.
Okay, so way before I ever posted anything. Okay, this is in
June. I really appreciate how much you guys pushed/help the last
time when we thought she might still be in Chicago a couple months
ago. So if any of you guys want to help, I'm requesting like
last time for each one of you who's interested to help me more.
Now, let's discuss what we know. Um, oh no, wait. This is after
I posted pictures because he's referencing, "Damn, how long ago
was this?" >> Dude, that just hits so good. It hits so
good that he's trying to disprove that he docks this person and
he's like, "Oh, wait. This is after I posted the Oh. Oh,
I almost want to time stamp on this to see if the chat even sees
what's going on there." >> Wait, when did I post pictures
in chat? Cuz this post he made was in June. But Des saying
>> May 28th.
Um, or he's saying Desi posted two pictures of Rose, one of which
face is visible, the other one in which she's at XYZ college.
Now, the face picture is obviously her. >> Oh, gay at XYZ
college. Now, the face picture is obviously her. And just to
be clear, the face picture Destiny
used and gave them is the one that they did find her with. Like
they that is the key piece of information that they used to find
her. So, like I don't understand how you can virtue signal about
how bad Kiwi Farms is, but you gave multiple pieces of personal
personally identifying information to them to find this person,
right? And say, well, I just wanted to find her. You can't say
I was like trying to do harm there. How can you say Kiwi Farms
is so evil? Your Kiwi Farms thread is so evil.
And then you give them all this information and then you admit
to it on Twitter as is alluded to by the first part of the clip
here where it's this where he says remember the only reason they
even found the rose person was because I posted the pics in chat
to bait them into looking. Um that's not even quite getting the
whole thing. They actually used the specific picture he posted
to find her. Right. Okay. So
it's evil.
They're they're harassing me. But also I wasn't doing anything
bad by posting those pictures. But also I definitely was only
me that made them find her. And also um Jtox's community is trying
to help them find her. JTO's communic community is participating
in a doxing campaign against her.
I don't know. How do you bounce around between all of these positions
at the same time? How can you hold and and make sense of these
positions?
I actually don't know.
I truly don't. Wait, I'm kind of lost. Why did he want to identify
Rose? Wasn't he being sued by Pixie? What's Rose got to do with
it? He wanted to identify Rose, I believe. And this is genuinely
like what he said. So if he thinks I'm being bad faith here or
something, I you don't even know what to say. I believe he thought
because she was in university, he like he knew she was in college,
right? I believe he thought, "Okay, I know that she's 18 cuz
she was she was in college when I was talking to her." Now, that
is absolutely not
dispositive of being a minor, that you're in college. Um, especially
because her school apparently had a program where you could graduate
early and start going to college to collect credits, which is
what she was doing, right? Or I don't even know if she graduated
early. Maybe she was still in high school and just doing classes
through the university. Not totally sure. Okay, >> we're
going into these places. >> Jesus Christ. >> They
ought to
clicked on a Rob thing and I just scared the out of myself. Holy
[__] Rob. Holy [__] Oh, here's a time
stamp. Cool. I click this time stamp. I actually want this time
stamp.
Let's go.
yeah, from apparently he's like trying to write letters to they're
all in like rer lighting redder letter writing campaigns to everybody.
I wonder if Putin could report him though for calling him the
>> and over again. >> He does over and Oh, it wasn't.
It was only once and then I was like, "Oh, that's bad. I shouldn't
do that." >> Um,
but he is trying to convince people to go record. >> I
don't know what the toss is on kick in so far as that goes.